fan 10 years ago you told your wife you
wanted to be a filmmaker what was going
on in your life at that time yeah yeah i
woke up one day 10 years ago and shocked
her by going hey you know
i think i want to make movies and she
was like what what do you mean what are
you talking about and um
i think what was going on in my life was
uh
i just
you know i was a photographer at the
time and i just loved stories and at the
time uh i was telling stories of one
frame then i was like oh be interesting
if i just could could
write a story you know write a movie and
you know i didn't know what the first
thing about
um
what making a movie is all about
and i wasn't even one that
watched a lot of movies and she was the
one she was one in the in our
relationship that watched movies and um
but i wanted to tell stories and and uh
so i
like went to amazon no i went to the to
uh this place in in dallas it's called
half-price books and um i would buy as
many books i could about screenwriting
or movies or what directors wrote and i
would just read that and um
get my hands on as much scripts as i
could and i spent the next like year or
two just writing and um
uh and that at that time the the dslr
camera came about
and um
canon came out and you start you know
doing great videos and i was like oh
this isn't and that seemed like a
natural transition from being a
photographer now it could be a
videographer um so
that was sort of the
the start of at all my kind of desire to
like
change things up tell more stories in a
different way um
and then she and she was like oh my gosh
you just started your photography career
and it's going good
why don't you open up a restaurant too
and do everything that's like you know
like percentage-wise difficult to do and
um so
uh i just i just became disciplined and
woke up each morning and tried to write
write
a sentence so
and then 10 years later
you know
you got to film
and previously were you
an early riser or was this a new routine
you were getting into
i think i'm i think i'm personally uh
um
an early riser
uh especially with writing there's
there's a for me personally
uh
i fi i find that from six to nine
a.m
there's a uh i write best there that
time and it's a struggle after nine a.m
so the i think it's because i get up
right away everything's quiet
and if something's brilliant that night
before
i have a better clarity of it some
people work at different hours but i
just found over the years
that was my
sweet spot
because i think it felt
like alone that nothing could
could bother me and you know i didn't
want to be on the computer and i could
be quiet and things like that so that
was my my sweet spot
though i don't wake up at six every
every morning it just depends if i'm
working on a project i
uh i would get up that early well don't
feel bad charles bukowski would start at
noon yeah yeah okay
but what do you think happens after 9 00
a.m
is it just something mental in your
brain i think it's because a couple
hours of our i think what happens
especially for me i was
um because your brain's always like
trying to solve problems solve like what
does this character have what's the
story what's happening so it's almost
like you're
constantly doing a rubik's cube and not
getting one side done you know and
that's how i always felt so after three
or four hours there's fatigue i think
for me um so i would take a break
or i would just force myself um
to work on something um and you know i
took it kind of seriously because i i
didn't
i think i got tired of not taking in
everything else so not seriously in my
life i was like what would what would i
wake up each day that i would enjoy and
try to get better at and
um
and and writing was something that was
personal you know for me that
that no one could uh take away um so i
didn't have to wait for
um
a producer or or an actor or if i was in
a band i didn't have to wait for the
drummer or the basis or i could just get
up and write and i think that was so
freeing and that's what i enjoyed
enjoyed about the idea of writing a
script
um
versus a novel you know a
script
in my head was like 100 page poem and i
always wanted to be a
poet for some reason uh you know and i
knew that each word
um
had a lot to it that
you know you can't waste waste the word
or space you know so that's
that's how i think i got better my
scripts weren't so tight um they were
just
on these things but i think now 10 years
later
um
they
you know i
cliches are correct for a reason you
know they keep saying like kill your
babies like what's that mean i was like
oh that's such a great line or a great
scene a great dialogue and like ah it
just doesn't fit you just kind of kind
of you gotta knock it out and i got a
little bit better of
um not crying when i have to kill my own
little baby babies but uh writing is
something i enjoy
so waking up each morning i get excited
for that but then you know i'm not a
robot so i get fatigued and tired out
does something have to have meaning
like an intense meaning for you to want
to take time to do it
um
i think
yeah i think so it had to mean something
for me or something for me to
investigate
um
but i think as i get older
i'm really investigating myself i think
that's what i'm trying to find even with
these stories with all these different
characters it's i think it's like
it's a way of me trying to understand
what
when i'm about and again that's very ego
driven being a director in this is oh
like this but you know but i think i'm
trying to see how i relate into this
world and and and what
what inspires me what makes me scared
what makes me happy and and um
you know
if i have a certain feeling i just hope
there's another human being that
possibly possibly might have the same
feeling so that's how
you know your work might be able to
connect i think if someone out there
you know
um
feels the same way and that's all you
could hope for as any artist is try to
get what you what you have in your brain
your heart out
and then if it comes out correctly
maybe someone might understand that you
know
and climbing the corporate ladder is ego
driven too so you know that artists get
a bad rap and writers and and i
understand that there's
a lot of internal stuff that comes out
in people's work but
you know people climbing a corporate
ladder also oh yeah
i was talking to a friend who
he was scientists
prior to becoming a filmmaker and he was
like
the the the cutthroat world of of being
in being a scientist and getting that
research grant getting this taking
credit for um certain findings and
things it's just
another thing hey that might be a movie
idea wow yeah that's true black swan of
uh yeah
science
world from the moment that you told your
wife you wanted to be a filmmaker what
immediate changes did you make in your
life in terms of craft or trying to
understand it was
um
reading and studying everything i could
about about um writing about um
you know how how
it's structured or how people how you
format and just the basics of things so
i kind of took it as my own
way of
um going go making my own school you
know of like
i want to learn this this is this is
interesting you know i just can't you
know
write on a um
napkin or or legal pad i just wanted to
see that you know i guess i could but i
i didn't so the changes i made was was
really making a commitment
um to trying to get better at it it
wasn't a thing that
i said this is going to be a career it
was a thing that was like i just wanted
to do it you know um so i didn't know if
it was even going to be
something feasible that that didn't even
cross my mind i just it gave me
something that i could wake up and and
do and challenge myself um
and and that i think i just never
reached a point where um
i was frustrated enough to quit i think
that was that was what um
the
screen ran because
obviously once you have a script then
you needed to
you know
you know produce the thing so you have
to shoot the thing and then
i think i just got
um
i just try to do it off because it
seemed fun you know call call my friends
up or my family and go hey could you
just you know come could we just spend
this weekend and then we and and do this
and um
and then that's how it all began you
know just to see if i could do it um
from start to finish
so and then when i did a short film
it was fun it was i liked the whole
process the storyboarding the getting
people together
mapping things out and and and seeing
the words come alive um
from from actors or or family members i
don't know i would call them actors but
but um
they were gracious enough to um
help me out so
you said previously you went to a
bookstore that was in texas sorry was it
in dallas or where it was yeah dallas
it was half it's called half price books
um which which um
people would sell back their books and
and that you know you could get all
these books for really really
um
you know cheap and and things like that
so i i would buy a whole bunch of uh
um
like
books about directors books on um i
think i got that robert rodriguez book
there the um the rebel
um book and then i got a couple other
tons of other things and then um then i
was searched for scripts scripts online
to read
you know thank goodness for the internet
you i mean it's like you could just get
anything you want and you know and and
and that's what i you know
um
that's what helped me you know you know
um just trying to get
learn and learn and learn and get better
were there other writers in the dallas
area or was that something that was not
part of
the culture at that time there's um
you know i've always had uh
i always wish i was able to be more
uh gregarious or open get involved more
of the
the community or specifically the film
community or theater um
i i just didn't wasn't able to do that
at that point because i think um
i didn't know where i was headed myself
so i just started just to write i think
it was such an isolating and freeing
thing um
but
i i really didn't meet too many other um
filmmakers at the time because i didn't
think
i was one i was just trying to write
right you know and um and and figure it
all out
i sort of did the same thing with my
photography um career
and uh you know there's many ways where
you you could go you could become an
assistant you can do this i just called
myself wrote a business plan and called
myself a photographer and shot as many
things as i can
weddings and and
things i could and and
figure out lighting and and and
all that kind of stuff and then
i think i work better that way um
uh it might not be the right way but
it at least i could kind of like
know you know understand understand what
i'm doing wrong but i i you know
oftentimes i wish i did have a mentor a
group and go hey what's you know my
second act sucks why am i why am i
always drowning in this and they could
say you don't have this there's not a
defined goal there's this you know
blah blah blah blah um
but i was really honest because if you
read a script like ordinary people if
you read a script like leaving las vegas
and then you read your script you got to
be sort of honest and go that's not
close yet you know you got to work on
that why why how come i can't why am i
turning each page like these other
scripts that i love and that was the
same thing when i was a photographer and
when i looked at photos in the magazines
i had to go i to be a photographer or a
working photographer the hard truth is
my photos have to look
as good or better than this so until i
was able to do that
and gain the confidence
i was just hard on myself in that way so
um
i just got to get better whether it took
two days or two years or 15 or 10 i was
um
ready to put in put in that because um
i don't know why you just kind of like
keep going because you wanted to get
better i think um
so i took the same approach with with
filmmaking and screenwriting um i i
wanted to write scenes that that made me
turn the page myself yeah
do you think it's okay to just not be
part of a group you know there's a lot
of pressure especially in western
culture to be part of a group and join
something and do all that and that's
great some people really rise to the
occasion i think some people are better
just by themselves internally
yeah that's a great i think it's up to
your personality and i think you need to
find that balance it's like sort of like
dieting i guess it's like you can't do
one extreme especially with filmmaking
writing itself is so alone but the
filmmaking process is so collaborative
so you need to work with other others
and be be able to do that so
so
that's what i wanted to do i wasn't
wanted to strictly be a writer i wanted
to work with other people but i love the
isolation of the writing process
but now i've learned
the the beauty of
rewriting and and and the input of other
people and and and
and getting notes and and getting go hey
this is
you know you got to you got to get into
the
to it faster you know you got to do this
oh this is
maybe not so
so um you know
so right for the for the story
so
i like i like taking notes um because it
it get it gets me to think of other
things because when you're writing for a
script it could take you three six
months four months whatever you're so
alone and um that maybe that's why other
people have writing partners um you know
so you could bounce ideas but to get
notes it gives me an idea oh i never
thought about that let me
plug that in and maybe i could come up
with something else
it's pretty freeing for me to to do that
and um
uh not take it personal you know
and and and maybe i'm just more
optimistic that go like people are
telling you this
not because they don't want you to make
a crappy story it's because they think
it could help and it's your job to
synthesize all that information
and see if it does i think that's that's
what happens that's even being a
director because you get like
so much
information and so many uh
decisions you have to make
um and you have to make it within split
seconds sometimes hey is this makeup too
heavy hey what's the color of that
clothes or is this location work on uh
are we going to do another take does
this the actor um feel safe you know i
think it just
you know
happens so much so
um
you really have to be on your toes
and and um be adaptable i think i think
that that's a um
a vital skill even for screenwriters is
to be adaptable
and um
to take to take notes well
and
feedback criticism feedback criticism
um
and go just get back to work and and
take it and you know what you could do
it
you make a version of the notes you
could do it and if you don't like it you
go back to the previous version and
continue that way but at least
you shouldn't have a
if you follow that process for that for
at least for me i wouldn't have a um
writer's block
you know because someone gave you a a
door go to this door it might might not
be the right door but you get to go
through it so you could write that out
you know
it doesn't fit i didn't feel right or
maybe
you know
i'm missing that scene we need to add
that scene in again so um
it's it's it's interesting process it's
it's definitely
sculpting you know it's you could
continuously
keep writing it's it's weird something
maybe it's it's funny just to drop the
pin and stop writing it because i can i
could i'll re-read this
re-read the script constantly or the
first page the first line and go
i gotta stop and i'm a little obsessive
now i take a break and you know um
even the rhythms i would read it out
loud the feel of the words
flow right you know um
so that's that's what i because i would
imagine if i was a reader
if i was reading this and if it's boring
or or that exposition is too long or the
state or the scene heading is too long
you know i need to cut that out you know
so that's that's sort of my process
lately
is cutting cutting cutting
i think that's being an editor because i
edit as well so you get used to um
cutting you know cutting pieces together
looking back on it now do you think you
made the right choice for yourself
choosing the filmmaking path knowing
that you wanted to challenge yourself it
sounds like you you don't compete with
others you kind of are very much about
challenging yourself
maybe i'm wrong
you know if i if i you know
think about it and um
you know i i'm very lucky to be able to
make that choice and and feel like it is
the right choice
um
uh
certainly it's it's not the easiest of
paths
um
uh to take you know it's it's
it's not like if you go
um to get your bachelor's and you get
your master's or phd and then you you do
your residency and you just
your and you pass a license
that you're going to be a psychologist
you know there isn't like routes and and
there isn't a structure that even
determines that you are um
so there's well there was blind faith i
think it just more of like
you do something
and then you get obsessed about it and
you do everything you can
to make it happen i think that's just
what happened what happened to me
um and filmmaking
ended up being a medium i was drawn to
because i
i kind of failed at everything else i i
was i wanted to be a musician and that
didn't work out i want to be a writer
that i didn't that that didn't work out
and i and i i was got into photography
and i got this and i was like wow you
could combine that on that's what
filmmaking was called i never even knew
that was possible you know
um
so once i knew that the possibilities of
it it maybe
i felt like a kid again i was like so i
think that's what
drove me in in in telling a story um
visually
with music with sound um
that that was
i was hook line and sinker you know and
and and coming up coming up with stories
each time and developing that and then
now you know working with
actors working with
art department working with the crew
you're like whoa this is awesome you
know you
you asked me before um about being
um you know isolated but now
you get to get out of your hibernation
and then play you know play with
everyone um i think that's the fun part
about filmmaking
and i think you said
just off camera you knew what you didn't
want you know and so
yeah that's a yeah exactly
exactly i i was very good at good at
that i was i'd maybe not didn't know
what i
want but i knew what i didn't want and
that's the same thing with like if i
compose something in a frame i know i
didn't want that in the frame i don't
want that in a frame so so what is it
that that's left in the frame um
so i took this sim
similar approach um
uh
you know i didn't want this to happen i
didn't want to have regrets i didn't
want to
um
you know uh
because i did i had those before i
wasted time i wasted this i didn't have
confidence i didn't have these things
and um
and so
when i started like you asked um i just
started one day at a time to see if i
enjoyed it and then um
if i didn't i probably would have been
obsessed with
uh
making ramen noodles that would be the
next thing how do you make those news
how do i get it right right texture oh
is this broth right okay then you want
to sell it then you want to do it so i
probably would have been obsessed with
something else if i didn't
you know
fall like in love with filmmaking
at what point in this journey did you
begin your production company
early on so once you sort of um
started you know the short films and
things like that i just
um
my first short film was called
balloons go pop
and then so i started go pop films
and um
and that started with the short films
that i was i was doing
and and then when we embarked on making
the feature film we partner up with red
productions um
and which is based in fort worth texas
and santa monica
and then um
and then
recently
we um started a commercial division of
uh rep representing different um
commercial directors
um for for that so it was a slope
process
um
it was me all the way back then and then
just learning the business of things and
then going hey you know
if this person could start
um a production company what's stopping
me from
legal paperwork you know things like
that so
so um that's that's exactly on
the path and i wanted to have something
i could um control as a business
can you talk about the process for
starting your business like step by step
what did you do
yeah so um
it depends on you know obviously if you
start out first if if it's just by
yourself
for
people out there
not knowing you could you could be a
sole proprietor so you don't have to you
know you could you don't have to um
start an llc
um
we i eventually moved into um go pot
films as an llc
to gain the protection of that but with
that in mind there's different fees
involved
state fees different you know taxes and
things like that um involved so
being like a producer versus like a
director or anyone like that you know um
you
you have to
sort of
be on top of
the
legal
regulations the taxes and things like
that um
so when you start like your production
company whether it's a commercial
production company um you
start charging people on fees um
producing video content editing
and then
and then you would charge that then
that'll be your revenue for the year and
you minus all your expenses and then you
know um
at first i was doing like all my taxes
and things
and then you want to find a good
good accountant after a while it gets a
little bit hairy and things like that
and for those who are
maybe starting a film or a movie or a
future film we
we had our films called all roads to
perrla prior to that it was called
sleeping plastic we started a sleeping
plastic
llc so the film itself is its own entity
um separate from go pop films you know
so each film that you'll make
will have its own um
you know life
um
so that's sort of the progression of
that of that so i had this idea
that wow okay i'll have go pop films
and we'll do um
films we'd do short films and hopefully
get into future films
and then
had this other great idea because
i was trying to get into the commercial
world of of of directing and video and
then instead of being in other people's
rosters oh why don't i create my own um
commercial vision and and and put uh and
collect
talent that i think
are that
have a great voice and and and
professional and could deliver
um
you know video content and and
and start started that way so i liked
the producing part after i did after i
was um
produced the first feature film i was
like oh
this is a pain in the butt
but you learn so much then you almost
like don't wanna for me i always like i
like producing i think
it became um
it was fun you know to put things
together um to help
a director
uh help their vision come alive with
this with the constraint of the budget
and that's that's that's the key you
know i was lucky to work with
red sanders and derek derek brown from
red productions when i first met them
they're like man how can we um
help you make your
your vision
and i was like that wow
everyone else they were very honest
about that and i remember derek
um brown was like
that's part about being a good producer
is helping
the director
um
get their vision out there come alive
and and that's what i would like to do
with other filmmakers has helped them
get their you know vision alive so i
love that aspect too you know
did you form the llc's yourself or did
you use a lawyer or some type of legal
service oh legalizing
legal zoom right there is it's um
pretty pretty easy that's that's what we
did for um go pop films yeah and and
then for the the movie as well no uh for
the movie um
red uh productions of red entertainment
and us we had a um a lawyer
on because the
the
i believe are um because we were
shooting in in oklahoma and texas so we
we had you know a couple different um
uh
kind of more um
uh kind of
the more more uh complicated things so
we
read red had a lawyer that he always
used um for their their films so we went
with the same one for because this this
would would have been their seventh film
that they've done our film so um
uh i was going with them you know it's
like it's i think that's the funniest of
the thing i've learned is this whole
like
industry
i've learned is it's about leverage
it's kind of interesting when i was
starting and and trying to push the
script around and they would go oh you
haven't done a feature film before
it's all you have this is all about
execution you got could you execute this
can you do that
and then
then once once i was fortunate enough to
work with red productions who've done
all these great films before
you know i was able to work with that's
like playing with someone who is better
at you in tennis so you get better so
those these last three or four years
working with all these people
was was a dream because it was i was
still absorbing and learning
on what this industry is about what's
producing about what's the legal work
what's how do you get things done um
you know it's like
like being a director is
is different
being a producer you can't have a
sustainable career if you don't make
your investors money back being a
director even though
you
the movie might not be a financial
success but it might you know garner
some accolades your career could keep
keep going so the producer's role is
really
um it's brutal you have it's strictly
business you know you gotta um
you gotta
make your investors money back and
that's a different different mindset you
know um
so i love both all the challenges of it
what's one thing that was a surprise
whether it was the paperwork forming the
llc talking to the attorney that you
were so glad that you'll always take
with you
moving forward
that maybe was a surprise whether it was
you didn't know when the fees for the
llc were do like just different things
which i know those kind of things when
you get an irs uh
letter coming at you that's a big
surrounding yeah yeah well it took out
the bone down yeah yeah so you don't
want to mess with
the irs so the surprises um there's
always a surprise you know the surprises
uh
um
if you get used to um
learning if you get used to your
mistakes and but don't repeat them
i think that's that's great because no
i mean you could go to
all these great schools like producing
and or business schools and learn a lot
of things but it's something not being
like trenches and go oh my gosh that 800
fee
it's
what's today october 15th
this has to be in you know it's like so
um oh you know did the actors do we get
the the the agreements done you know
what uh
the the agents come and talk and did we
get this sign
so
the surprise is
get everything in writing
sign everything
um it's all business you know there's a
reason that's why it's called
the movie business
not
the movie let's make vans art you know
it's it's it's uh
it's uh you gotta enjoy that aspect of
it uh but if you love storytelling and
you know how to
um
kind of play the play and learn the
rules of the movie business and and then
um
i think you'll you know enjoy it
great yeah
yeah no no one wants to get a letter
yeah no one wants to get a letter from
the irs
and then you know and that's one of
those things where you want to call
right away yeah even if you're on hold
for two hours yeah it's one yeah
it's it's all those things and there's
fees and they and they'll just
keep keep going so
um you know the things i get i guess the
thing that um surprised me probably
is uh
once you think you have it all sent and
done there's always something else you
know oh there's like
i thought we did that then the
deliverables didn't get deliver that or
then wasn't that signed or
what do you mean you know it's like you
have to be you have to be very thorough
yeah
when you formed your production company
did you take out a loan to purchase
equipment yeah um
so
when we when i first started before
on the equipment was on just you know
like
your dslr
on cameras your your um
your uh
sound lights and everything so it was it
was
credit cards you know those credit cards
um
i did i didn't do a per uh like a
personal loan and this was like
years ago 10 plus years ago yeah and
then um
but then as you get
more involved and you know
what what's going when we've
switched from um sole proprietor to llc
that's when we you know you you had
investors in in in the company so then
and then you had capital and equity and
things like that that you have to
um sort out but
i i was just like any other small
um business owner with it with their
dream and
and
credit cards
that's it's a rough rough game i i had a
friend who who um
opened up this bar
with eight
nine credit cards
and it became um the most popular bar
like
it won like most popular bar
in the world like
um
like couple years back it's called
employees only and uh and i remember way
back when and they had this dream and
they did it it's not
a good uh start but it was the only
start i had because i wanted i wanted to
do it you know
um
and i i didn't have like i didn't go to
the bank and go hey i need fifty
thousand dollars to start this i didn't
go to small business loans um i kept my
overhead low
that's the thing so then once you have
start having jobs
um
you know then you could pay things out
so the key is keeping your overhead low
which means you know don't be straddled
with with um
rent
payroll
um if i would spend on anything i didn't
spend that much on on equipment i spent
more on marketing
um i would do that
because uh so
that's what i would
would
we still do you know
yeah don't be late with that credit card
payment because oh yeah twenty nine
dollar late fee then yeah
and then you get a call
eight o'clock on a sunday morning
yeah
i'm gonna speak to van please yeah yeah
exactly
you know yeah and yeah you asked
that question like is it was it the
right path you know um
it's the path of an entrepreneur i think
there's there's an inherent stress that
no one sort of talks about all the time
of whether
whether it's
whether it's your credit cards whether
it's your investors whether it's
getting distribution i'm going to get in
this film festival i'm going to get that
after all
years of this you've come comfortable
being uncomfortable so
you you start to also become smarter and
become a better business person i always
love it when i see signs that says been
in business since 1984 i've been in c
it's like that's awesome you know how
hard is this maintain any business
there's a stretch amount of time
whether you're shining shoes or this
it's the same thing with them you know
like getting a movie um
so
uh
i kind of
had to tell myself
uh to take a chill pill
and take one day at a time or i'm going
to get an ulcer and a goiter if i keep
worrying about the are we going to get
in this film festival i'm going to do
that are we going to do this it's like
then you sit back it's like
okay if you do then what
if you do then what
it all comes to back down to why did you
start 10 years ago i love writing i love
doing this so i always wanted to try to
tell myself to not make something i love
um
an albatross
you know so i have to
really
remind myself of that every time you
know so okay is this what you want to do
okay
get better don't you know don't be
don't become cynical
um things like that
how many people were involved when you
started your production company and then
now how many people are involved when i
started it was me and um my wife
and uh now
um
it is me
uh
with um
one two like four other folks
and a whole bunch of interns
um and uh
and a roster of really great um
creatives and directors
so so uh it's become like a little a
little group um
and uh
and you know i'm very fortunate of that
to to find on teammates who who want to
go through the um
battlefield battlefield of
uh being part of a production company so
we started out small as just
like anyone like you know i'll be
sitting out there going how do people do
it you know what do you have to do um
so
i just started it didn't worry about the
equipment
um if there was a bigger job
um to do we would rent rent it i didn't
want to buy 20 30 40 000 worth of
equipment
and have it sit there for a year to let
it depreciate and not get its value
so
um
so now you know um
you know everything's taking a hit now
with with the pandemic um even you know
we have that we also have a sales uh a
sales rep that represents um go pop
films and directors in the midwest and
southeast so
what they do is they pitch the ad
agencies and art directors on our roster
of directors and they will send um
if there are um
treatments or spots or things that we
could bid on so things like that we also
go to uh
direct to brand or director companies
you know that that need video content
um but at the moment just
uh things are obviously production
is that holding it's picking up but you
want to be safe and
we and that's the key key uh low
overhead keep your overhead so you so
you could maintain and sustain so when
when the economy and when comes up you
you'll be able to
position yourself so if we think about
it right now
as we are in pre-production
that's how i've we've talked about it is
like um we're in pre-production so when
production comes we're ready to ready to
go so you know like being able to uh
service service our clients and things
like that to our best of our ability i
think that's where we're at right now
pandemic error
right and just just with other booms and
busts like let's say the dot-com
you know when things were really good in
the 90s um it also can you talk about
not getting maybe too confident knowing
that there will be a winter and there's
always a winter you know
yeah i think the the life cycle the life
cycle of uh
of things and that
you just have to kind of be steady and
and
and know
especially with with this you might have
a lot of clients or maybe your business
has one big client but what if they just
what if they
disappear what if your client was
a lot of the travel industry right now
or what if you know where your clients
were
but then what if you weren't busy then
you also you ha
you have a plastic company and they're
needing a lot of things so it just it
just all depends where your position in
the market
um changes so you just have to be
um
what's this thing uh
uh prepare for the
no expect the worst prepare for the best
or vice versa it's one of those things
where
you know you
you can't be a fat cat when you you know
you just kind of like keep going because
there will be lean times and the same
thing with films when films come out
like we just released our film
uh
we don't know where what the market
that's the toughest thing about
filmmaking because you have a thing that
you made you started three two four ten
years ago but when it reached market
is it the right time for this film does
this does this touch a nerve is it is it
two years too early two years too late
so it's the same time when you release a
product is it right or not maybe it
catches on later
what was that with donnie darko it
wasn't so
so hot here in the states it goes
international it comes back it's a five
year five year process it happens with a
lot of different things
so um so for anyone who's
you know had a short film or other films
i think you'd go back and
focus on that creating
because you can't determine the market
but you can prepare for it i think
that's that's the uh
the balance you have to do you know have
have uh be prepared for lean times
and
[Music]
that'll be the best way to go about it
what area of business does your
production company focus on well we have
um
a lot of different directors who
have whether it's um healthcare food
fashion documentary so so we
we covered a lot of different industries
so we we
we could tackle them all so
i figured this out because
when i was you know as me as a director
trying to get on into a production
company
i wasn't going to get hired for
a comedy spot you know because my real
or my work isn't comedic
i wasn't going to get hired for for um
food
because i didn't do any food
you know i had i had a um kind of
documentary uh feel those are the
different jobs that i i would get more
cinematic
so
i thought
we will have our company
instead of
um
turning down jobs
let's find the best directors who does
food who does cars who does fashion who
does products who does um travel
and that's your roster so if you're if
you're a client that needs
um
cinematic images
that need to have your brain or message
um elevated and tell a story
that's what we do we want to help you
tell your story and that that's our
selling point like bringing
cinematic imagery and and production to
to elevate your your brand and your
company's message um
so it could be wine industry it could be
um
you know
fashion it so we pretty much tackle it
how do you know these directors are a
fit for your company first uh
so when we we see that the directors
work
and and it it has to be a certain um
uh level and certain sort of um
uh voice that they're telling
second i meet with them
and
if they have a similar
um
philosophy or personality because we
don't want to work with jerks you know
there's already so many walking around
it's it's hard it's you know when we
want to work with um good people who are
focused on um
and producing really good work and also
um
are nice and we had this motto of work
hard and be nice you know uh
of that aspect so
the directors not only have to be
talented they just have to be nice
people because when you're on set and
when you're dealing with clients
who wants a temperamental director or
temple it's like we should be fortunate
to be working for you you know we
we
i want to be surrounded people with that
same attitude of like how can we help
you it's not like i mean
businesses it's like
nothing you can't take anything for
granted every little
um
every little
job every big job
it's a job that should be treated the
same highly valuable you know um just
like i remember neiman marcus
i think
someone's telling me
the sales training or someone's training
that you treat everyone who walks
through the door the scene someone who
could look like their transient versus
someone who has a mink coat you never
know who's who
right so that's the same thing with an
email with a call with
if your client base um we we're just
fortunate to be able to see if we can
help you and that's that's the type of
directors if they have that attitude and
they they they want to um put their nose
to the grind um
and then they do and funny enough a lot
of our directors have a background in
photography similar to me so so they
they they're actually started as
photographers too so it's nice to have
um it's just sort of that
i know visually that they they could
capture what they they want you know
they could they could either act as
their own um dp or work with dps or and
things like that so funny enough a lot
of our directors are shooters themselves
and what's interesting is too sometimes
just like you said the mink coat versus
the transient analogy sometimes in la
the mink coat the more show the less
someone actually yeah you know that's
the weird part about being here and
maybe that's the same in new york city
too but like a lot of times that's just
a front it's not real you know exactly
and and and
you just and
you know
you just never know you know and so
um
so we those are the type of directors or
or graphic designers or animators or
people we want to work with even in our
crew and and things like that um i know
it starts they always say it starts from
the top and hopefully we could
create a culture that that is
professional
but also
um
creates that um atmosphere where your
voice is heard no one's you know
above anyone else
everyone's open to suggestions and and
and you know
that one's artistic but we don't need to
be um van gogh here and be all crazy if
you don't get your way you know
what are your day-to-day duties with
your company maybe pre-covered
now during covid
so
you get up
you know you fire up that
laptop or desktop and then
you go through your emails um a lot
right now let's let's talk
since it's really right now um covid
is
research
a lot of research
that's going on
uh in terms of uh uh
new um
clients that we want to kind of work
with we're in a new industry a we have a
um
a new industry that we're trying to
penetrate is the the golf and luxury
resort industry prior to covid
we've got a great couple great directors
who who do that so we're trying to match
match
match that up now that's the commercial
side but for the film
um
the film side uh is
uh
we have a couple i have a couple
different films in the in development
right now and one uh one
um
is uh
we're developing the script um or just
shaping it up to be to go out um for um
attachments and things like that so the
last
couple of months i've been trying to get
that script right
and then and then
and then also we're also you know
producing um
this uh
feature film for uh yifki she's a dutch
filmmaker it'll be her first um
feature film uh she her her short film
lily has been screened over 50 film
festivals around the world it's a me too
horror film and her and phosphor is one
of her um first feature film we're
fortunate enough to be producing that so
we're trying to get
things lined up for that as well so
like we were talking about before
there's still a lot of things that could
be done even though we're not everyone's
getting used to zoom and all this stuff
but it's it's laying laying the seeds
and and
and um getting that all done so that
takes most of the day
um
and also preparing for um
we just released the film like
two weeks or two you know september 25th
um last month and then um
so we're we're still pushing that as
well you know um so a lot lots of little
different things on on our plate
and so maybe pre-coven was it responding
and and and and post covet or during
covet is now hunting
doing research yeah hunting doing
research um
and and because because you don't know
who's going to be
left standing it's a weird thing you
know even while we were talking with our
sales agent who who
we've released our film for north
america but we're still um you know
entertaining international territories
like germany uk ireland and all these
other parts but
but because of
the pandemic of things
different companies have gone under
who's staying so it's almost like
everyone's waiting to see
um
what's what's left who's standing
where's the you know um
so they're you know everyone's
adjusting and it's it and
so you kind of have to take a
optimistic um
point and um
and and do your research and and tread
water um until
there's a break you know
yeah it's a it's very interesting well i
mean for commercial
commercial work we used to
um you know we had a lot of shoots
postponed um you know cancel and things
like that so
uh
um you know you you do you deal with the
blows and you know you you take it take
it with a chin but you
you guys still stand up and
prepare as as when things open up
what have you found is the best way to
make money as a filmmaker get
involved in anything that's possible
that will help you get better as a
filmmaker whether it's editing
um peeing writing
on
shoot
taking any job
any job because that helps you as a
writer be a security guard be a bus
driver be on
amazon prime delivery
because you're building
different experiences and you could
write about that
and still have a living
and
there's only until you reach that
kind of threshold where
you can make a sustainable career with
with with your art or with your
filmmaking but when you're starting out
you take as many jobs as you can
teach if you can
teaching helps you know any any kind of
thing so
i think you just have to hustle
hustle find any job
survive pay the bills and that if you
can do that that actually teaches you
how to get a film made because it's not
getting a filmmaker is the exact same
way because it's not easy you know you
have to use every little ounce of your
creativity your your experience your
inexperience just combine it on and will
will it will it to happen so
if you have to uber drive for two months
um so you could write for two months
you have to make those sacrifices
what was one of your best part-time jobs
that really helped you actually be
creative and then maybe what was one of
your worst
uh being
being a um i always said the
two things that made me become a better
photographer not a filmmaker
photographer was being a waiter
and being
um
a wedding photographer
you see
people at their worst it's like if you
can handle that if you can handle the
pressure
of those things
uh
that
that would help i think it's it's it's
like because you know what happens
plan a never works i was playing b c and
d so if you could get that in your your
your
dna and your bloodline to always have
plan d ready um that's
what i found filmmaking is about is
adjusting you know adjusting um
so the job that i learned was because
you know how to read folks
read people if if they're happy with the
food or not food or if they don't want
you to come near their table um
those are those are great instincts to
learn so when you're making a film are
you giving the actors enough space or do
you think does this person need more
direction this person doesn't need any
direction you have to know each does
this crew member need that do we need to
sit down so each one you have to read
people differently and under stress
stress is caused by
lack of time and lack of money
so
that's what happens in filmmaking so
people get
it's like bees running around like ah so
if you know that's gonna happen
and
and immediately find the solutions
um
so
they say never let them see you sweat
but
i try not to let people see you know me
all riled up but i'm also crying in the
inside and i just
i'm just smiling through but um
but being a waiter helped me doing that
you will learn to think on your feet
yeah any customers any kind of customer
service
thing um
your second part of the question what
what job that i didn't like or
yeah well i mean um what was maybe and
maybe they're the same ones that that
was the toughest because i was wondering
what was one that actually helped your
creativity which sounds like learning
how to read people yeah the other two uh
yep
it's being empathetic that's why you
know any job that could could get you
feeling what the other person is going
through the more you can do that i think
that will help with your writing they'll
help with your direction you your
producing skills because once you kind
of
could train yourself to walk in other
people's shoes
you gain empathy different perspective
and then you you gain um an
understanding it might not always be the
right understanding but you gain a
different perspective so you don't be so
narrow-minded on your particular review
and um i think that start then that that
breeds creativity you know that's the
spark that kind of
whoa
now i could create this because um
this person feels that way you know um
you you try to get all that energy and
form something yeah
yeah and maybe to learning how to
de-escalate a situation and so whether
you're working in food service or you
know at someone's wedding
or supermarket there's going to be
people that either going to try to test
you or they're really angry and just
learning how to de-escalate before the
blow up
exactly i think i think that's it that's
a it's a it's a skill you know i i was a
portrait photographer
and
to get someone
to trust you to to relax to
to get you to do what
you want
or them uh what how how do you get a
sitter to to to give you a pose that you
like it took a lot of time you know it's
it
it deals with trust and how do you gain
that is like giving something from
yourself to to the sitter you can't
always take take take
so that i take that on
with me working with people with with
the crew you know we talked about how
can i help how can we help you what
could i tell myself that will make me
vulnerable and um for you to
you know for for us to gain that trust
and that respect because
uh i think that that is that's important
that's important that's important um
you know
just important way to treat treat your
neighbor this is with respect and you
want to understand how what their life's
about and i like that giving of yourself
while you're on set so if you have an
actor that maybe
you know they can deliver but maybe for
whatever reason it's a tense situation
and you're not sure why
i mean you know was it another person we
interviewed talked about sets being
pressure cookers
and sometimes there's personalities on
sets whatever it's just
getting that person to feel comfortable
i like that giving
yeah and that's and
and that takes um
it's like chess it's like two three you
have to think like two or three um steps
ahead you know like
um
and
i hate to say it's like almost knowing
the situation
[Music]
and how to diffuse it or manipulate it
and calm things down if you want someone
riled up what would get someone riled up
if you need that reaction if you want
someone
in shock
like this this is an interesting story
i forget who the photographer was but
they had to do um like
um
a shoot of let's say
uh i think it was like the queen of
england or something like that right and
then they're like oh she always gives
the same look
how you want something different um
so
they were shooting at the end was like
oh she she knew
like the queen was like a dog lover or
something at the end was like oh
how how
how was your ride here and she said it
was great until we ran over a dog and
then it clicked you know and then so
it all these stories and when i was
younger i was naive to think like
photography is the truth but no there's
three truths your truth my truth and the
truth so if i wanted you to
to pose a certain way
you know if i want to light you in a
certain way
the city would never know
you know it's so it's so odd to me to
to that power later like oh you could
kind of manipulate light
and
story
differently so
i try to hold that kind of
um
that kind of like knowledge kind of
precious in terms of like
understanding and
and one
like if we're on the same page and the
scene is about pain
how
how do we go there and you need
some extra help on that
um that's where i think i could come in
and maybe help and go
let's talk that out or maybe we don't
need to talk about that out just feel it
just let it rip you know so
each actor is totally different the same
with working with a dp
um
you gotta trust each other that's why
it's fun being a director you hire you
work with people because they know what
they're doing you just get out of the
way and maybe just like could you try it
this way and they're like okay you know
it's it's easy now it's it's like
for me
i i i because everyone who you're
working with you i trust them to
just do their what they're there to do
and and that's the best part you know um
i think that's where
magic happens
and just going back to when you talked
about working at weddings yeah and and
they can be pressure cookers too
sometimes it's not actually the bride
that's the problem it's the family oh
yeah it's the family you know
did you make sure did you get that you
know oh were your wedding photography
because i got that same thing this uncle
was like i've worked yeah like well i i
got about 300
photos of them
twirling you need another one yeah i got
you know but again it's the client and
you know clients are always right you
gotta like suck it up but
i did 14 weddings and
that was enough
that was enough for me and i knew um
that's that skill set is totally
different you know it's it's definitely
great and there's some great wedding
photographers out there um i think um
you know
i got a glimpse of it and uh
remember i told you i was a quitter i
quit all the time you know i quit when
photography
yeah
when did you know it was right was it
the last one
when i had anxiety
and going i don't want to do this
anymore so um
i think when you have that feeling of
like
uh
i think it's like i made a point if i
and
if it felt off
um i'm gonna try my best not to feel
that bad you know even if i have to get
another job and become a floral
assistant um
whatever it is um i didn't mind going
backwards
because i didn't think it was going
backwards i think it was safety you know
in terms of um i want to get used to to
being where
where
i want to be i didn't know where i
wanted to be i knew i didn't want to be
that remember we talked about like i
knew what i didn't want to do and
i didn't want no i i want to be a
filmmaker and that was like only until i
was 35 years old you know i didn't know
that's
that's that's the path so
um
so when i would quit when when um
it didn't feel right
and for too long i just didn't want to
um waste
um a year or two years being somewhere i
didn't want to be
no weddings are tough for almost like
high school reunions
there's a lot of ego and sometimes it's
not coming from the writing room yeah
yeah and and um
and there's certain there's only a
certain amount of
um
you know i'll be in a church and
the photographer is not allowed to use
their
flash but everyone else is allowed to
use their flag and i'm like oh i can't
eat it so but that's minor i enjoy i
value the 14
weddings
it gave me that
learn how to deal with pressure and
because you've missed the moment you
don't go back to another i do you know
hey can we um take two uh let's let's
take let's do another take and like
that was it sir um so
uh if you get used to that pressure um
uh
and the pressure to uh
it's okay if you do fail because what's
the worst thing
for me the worst thing in life is to die
so
if when i if it's not going to kill me
i could survive it you know um
i might not pay rent the next month but
i could survive so that that would i
just tricked my brain
to um
to do weird things
dan can we talk about your life as a
daydreamer i understand that daydreaming
is very important to your creative
process what's daydreaming like for you
when you were a kid and what is it like
for you now i don't know i always
thought you know you grow up and you get
in trouble for daydreaming and things
like that and
but sometimes you just can't help but
stare outside the window and and let
your you know let your mind go and i
remember as a kid um
i don't know if you do it
you just do it uh
everyone daydreams until the they
they're told not to i think and i think
i wish
um
we could nourish that more and and and
nor and i think uh there's a lot you
know that could be
harnessed through that i think um
i think uh
that was always a maybe a joke or a
thought that maybe i could become a
professional daydreamer and things like
that
but i think now in terms of like
how i apply it
i i apply it as a way to maybe my own
way of meditating or my own way of
trying to find solutions and ideas and
and um and
maybe my own way of being in the moment
or in the present so i i find
daydreaming a uh
really useful tool for me in terms of
creating
um i know it sounds kind of weird it's
they're stupid but um
it's like it
it helps
if i'm having like a
uh if i see or hear things and it could
lead to different things so i could just
kind of tune out you know and focus on
that specific thought or that specific
noise or sound and it could take me you
know to different um places
uh i don't
sound so like
weird but it's it's it's relaxing
you know
where have you done some of your best
day dreaming can you do it let's say at
a coffee shop
you could do it i think i i think yeah i
think you could you could do it anywhere
you could do it
um uh practically not while you're
driving but uh you but but if you're
just sitting sitting by outside sitting
at a park um sitting by yourself uh
um
that you just take a moment and and um
you think of think think of thoughts
think think of ideas and let that like
let that kind of uh permeate and and and
last blossom you know um
you know it could be even the thought of
hawaii just the word hawaii then it
starts then you could focus on the the
sound of it the vials and and what that
takes you there's just different
connections that you can make so
um then it could take you to coffee to
pineapple to to different things and
then your brain is
visualizing these these image these
images and then i think
um once you kind of
get get used to doing that for me
uh i do it just because
i i get lost in thought
because something might it might be my
head and then it takes me somewhere and
i find that um
useful
and is daydreaming the same as
meditation or they're different
um
they're probably in the same world and
it's
linguistics of it of it on if you are
meditating and focusing but but
i think daydreaming is cool is because
you could set
ideas you could set things and um in
your head and uh and you could
you could try to implement those
if you could you know
remember it it's it's i guess it's
it's the opposite when you dream at
night right when you're dreaming at
night and we have all these dreams
that pop up of things all of a sudden
you might have a dream like
hey why is that guy in my third grade
class in my dream you know it just pops
up right and then when you're
daydreaming you're like the same thing i
was like
oh but it seems like you're uh you know
you're conscious of that i think that
opens up
um
opens up your your your creative space
to accept ideas
you know and they go oh like when i get
stuck writing
i guess that's why people hey you know
go for you go for a walk you go this you
how does the ending really work how do
these subplots come together how does
that and then people say
you know they fi have ideas in the
shower or these things these moments you
know i think those are important having
those moments um i think it starts with
a little bit of daydreaming because
once you focus too much
it's like you're not seeing
the possibilities with that's like
behind you or beside you you're so
narrow you're narrowed into the script
this story but if you let go and start
thinking
about the cup that's on the table of
your character and how that cup reminds
you of your grandmother's cup and then a
grammar when she was born here and then
that leads to this oh she used to love
this flower that was purple maybe that
flower ends up somehow back in your
scripts you just never know you know so
it's it's making associations with
things that
that um
sometimes don't don't connect
immediately so i think that's what helps
me so so i think that's a great tool
especially
writing but then you have to there's all
these things
you have to find a thread
otherwise they just become images it's
both story you need you need that thread
um so that's the other thing now is to
pull all that dreaming together and have
it structured
and that's the
that's the battle of screenwriting
did you used to get in trouble in school
for daydreaming with teachers
i might have got to you and use of time
wisely i think
so
the unsatisfactory thing um
i think that you know i might have
gotten that
um
but i always try to avoid
getting in trouble but
you know doesn't mean you can't be
sneaky and
and they dream well no one's looking so
yeah
if you were going to teach a class on
daydreaming let's suppose
you know the the idea of daydreaming has
changed and now it's more reinforced
let's suppose they take from different
people einstein different you know just
and you put it in together into a course
what would uh what would day one be like
in your daydreaming course
yeah day one i would um
you know just
introduce the thought of it and talk
about what will what we would do during
this this term and kind of structure it
and go like and and and and tell folks
that um
what is the goal you know what's our
goal
with this you know there's science
there is you know technology there's
things but there's also this thing
called mystery you know so
um
to offer and that's where the beauty of
new innovation comes from
i think so i was
first talk about what they you know get
everyone's opinion what daydreaming is
you know i i
there isn't a specific answer that's how
you feel but um
then talk about how we were just so
bombarded by visuals and and especially
nowadays and and not understanding
um what the visual language is well how
do we why do we
feel certain things when we see certain
type of imagery you know maybe getting
the same page and and say the first
third of our course would be
understanding a visual language
what does that mean when we drive down
sunset boulevard why do why do all these
colors why what does yellow and
and purple due to us versus
gray and pink and these things so
um
so that helps so then when you're able
to understand that then maybe you could
start to visualize and that's
part of daydreaming you know daydreaming
you want to be a filmmaker what does
that entail i didn't know but in
definitely until
getting off the couch let me start with
that and then definitely until maybe i
should go to half-price books and buy a
book
uh maybe
what's the story you think about story
and and then you
you think about themes and then that
could lead
lead somewhere um
so yeah
well first third of class uh course
talk about
visualization how do we interpret visual
language
uh second third is to apply that to
let's let's let's work on
our thoughts and our way to daydream and
recollect those things and how that
could help and how long could he do it
in 30 seconds 30 minutes whatever and
then the
last third of the course would just to
be um
to understand what what we did what's
the goal of it and
was it successful
how could we um use this in future
applications of creative work you know
that's
that's what uh maybe the first class
would be like
you mentioned mystery
does mystery always having having a
does mystery always have to be let's say
solving a crime or figuring something
out in science could it also be
figuring out a character
doesn't even have to be some criminal or
scientific element it's just figuring
out
who they are why they did something why
they said something like exactly i think
so it encompasses so much and i think
it's it's like you know i think
um i think that's what's fantastic about
it because it it it incorporates the
unknown and incorporates things that we
maybe have on the tip of our tongue and
we want to explore and understand it we
want to solve things um we're driven by
a mystery um we
that takes us
to new places i think that's what's
what's uh really neat and dynamic of
understanding how to how to use mystery
in your own work um
to tell stories to create suspense to
to um
you know and then to have resolution
because you know because we need
i think
us humans we need closure
and and understanding but we also don't
need to be handheld at least at least
for stories some folks might but for me
as a as a storyteller i'm not i
i always think the audience is smarter
than
definitely smarter than me and and you
don't want to treat them
too like
hand holding everything so you want to
leave things to interpretation
but i also don't want to be so abstract
that
no one understands what the story is
about you know so um
so those are two different things i'm
battling with right now and mystery is a
a good way to
you know to keep me inspired and and
and you know
work my way through through life
trying to figure things out
what's what's an example of a handheld
story from a writer versus something
that's too abstract
um
okay i guess every you know probably
david lynch is uh is that is there um
and a handhold would be more of
you know two plus two equals four that
that um boy meets girl
they fall in love
um
versus boy meets girl for other things
could happen
you know things like that um so you as a
as the storyteller um
it's i always think it's like
on being a chef right we have these
ingredients
and and the way you use it whether it's
you know where
where the where it hits you it's how you
use these elements of story to do it you
want to hand hold someone from the end
and go this person is definitely the
killer or this person is definitely the
bad bad guy who planted the seed who's
trying to get them to break up and
remarry her or things like that um
uh so it's up to you know up to each
chef and and the audience is so vast and
diverse like a lot of people are
definitely not gonna like
some of the dishes i cook because it's
it's not their flavor
on profile
um but does that mean
um
you could deny the execution of it or
the craft of it it's like if you
don't like country music but you like
you know uh
indie rock you cannot deny johnny cash
was a
skilled
and talented musician it's just a taste
so that's what happens i think in terms
of what how you tell stories
and hand holding is a great great device
um
but for me as as a chef
i you know i don't want to add too much
salt kind of like as things goes i'll
leave it to the audience a little bit
more to
piece the flavors together
do you think that people look at
daydreaming in a positive way that's a
tricky question
i was going to say yes but then
i'm gonna say no because
everyone will be talking about it more
and how is that because it's it has more
of a negative connotation because it
means you don't get anything done maybe
if we
re rewrite that narrative in terms of
day dreaming as a step to execution into
work where you're daydreaming of being a
making
great leather purses
you know then
you that happened where you're
daydreaming of solving um going to the
space you know these things
it starts with some sort of idea
planted in a
a world that seems so far away
but if you you set it and you do the
work it could be attainable i'm not
saying it all is hap can happen but at
least it gives you hope that an idea can
be
reached you know tried tried for um
so i think when
if you ask parents maybe they don't
think it's a good good thing if their
kids are always daydreaming
but um
you know
i i i hope they it it changes because
um i love that word you know i love the
word dream it's it's it's it's
that means um
we are
an ideas thought out of and it could be
possible
um
but we have to sometimes enjoy that
process of making it possible in the
result the result of that dream you know
um
so that's the tricky part tricky part
how does daydreaming help us reach our
goals
daydreaming you know um
it helps you start with an idea it helps
you um
[Music]
be open and i think that is and it's in
itself a success if you are able to open
and accept new ideas and think of things
that are possible
that that helps because we need goals
how does daydream get us there
it gives us a shovel they give us a tool
it gives us
things that we
we maybe feel like we we can't
accomplish and we might make an an
excuse hey i can't get
um this degree because i don't have
money
but you could start by daydreaming and
if you if that daydream
makes you become obsessive makes you
become passionate makes you become
driven then that that's helpful but if
that daydream turns into a nightmare uh
then it could lead you to another
daydream
so
that's where i think it's it's useful
because there's many many chances many
doors out there where um that can open
daydreaming allows you to hop hop around
and then
when you want to sit on something
then that sets
a path to your goals
do you ever give yourself a limit though
for daydreaming like okay
i've daydreamed at least an hour today
and i think i've reached my limit now
i'm going to get back to something
that's more linear
yeah yeah i well no i don't think i do
it subconsciously i think um
i think it happens that's why i think
it's a little bit different than um
meditation because you designate a
certain time maybe i do it so much that
i don't even know i could be washing the
dishes and then
though i'm washing the dishes and get
getting it done
i have just
i just went to ethiopia
you know and the ethiopia just opened up
this new
type of um
bread that i wouldn't want to discover
while i'm washing dishes you know it's
so
um
i don't think you could do enough maybe
i'll go there i'll go the opposite i was
like
until it
hinders your goal
i think you need to keep
exercising that muscle
just like walking or breathing or doing
things and if it helps you
reach goals
then it's useful
if it doesn't that means
uh
it's it's it's an excuse
and that's a fine line i think
that to walk so
um and that's the practice and that's
going to be everyone's journey to to to
go hey i've been daydreaming that's why
i don't i'm not getting anywhere i've
been daydreaming oh that's why i'm here
so it's that it's it's that
uh half um you know glass
half full half empty kind of thing so
it's going to be up to each individual
to kind of figure out if it's it's if
it's for them you know
or there or if they're doing it too much
you mentioned you liked the writer
charles bukowski and i have a quote here
from his 1989 book hollywood and i'll
change the wording a little bit just to
clean it up but i believe he said people
became so used to seeing crap on film
that they no longer realized it was crap
do you feel that way about movies today
easy
he's a straight shooter isn't he
so uh um
you know
it's funny after
after
completing my film
first feature and
it's such a miracle to create anything
to get anything done
um i'm very bad bad at um
critiquing or criticizing because what
whether it's crap or or or oscar-worthy
or just
magnificent
that's again up to the audience you know
as a creator all you can do is is hope
that you
you got
out what was inside um out there
uh for for me and movies that are hey
you know um
this is this one not
you know
not better than the other
um i see enjoying mom because if you if
it's just someone's sweat and tears that
went through it i i tend to look at that
more um
of it and i'm so
sorry to disappoint on charles but i
don't kind of um
i'm not that controversial to say
that it's crap you know i don't have
that i don't think i have that authority
because i make a lot of crap
it goes back to two what you're talking
about uh hand-holding the audience
versus being too abstract would you say
a lot of tentpole movies
are hand-holding and maybe some people
want that
yeah
yeah and that that that's the taste and
you know i remember i don't know if i
was in school or someone said hey if you
want to make a lot of money shoot for
the middle
so
you know
but it there's a place where every
everything you know i always i was i was
thinking about that
that funny thing about you know 10 of us
like black licorice you know and why you
know why does black licorice hang around
all the time because
but
if i could ever have a career like black
licorice i'll be very happy you know i
don't have to please everyone just
sometimes you know your work
isn't for everyone um
but sometimes you want to go for that
joyride um you can't watch a million
dollar baby
three times in a row and
you know it's like it's great but it's
brutal but maybe you just want to go for
a joyride and and every every medium
every art
has has that you know i can't eat
um
rich
tomahawk ribeye or something like that
and it's i'm gonna get gout and then or
every day but i could eat
pizza every day you know but then
there's levels of that so um i know i'm
talking a little bit weird and abstract
of it so
yes
um big hollywood films
has a big place because people enjoy it
um artsy art house films
people enjoy that too it's just giving
people the the opportunity to see them i
think that's more important and then
everyone can
whether marketed differently or what
but um that's a different different
conversation just to say who's doing
what but it just takes
but you think about it like look at all
the films that when when the oscars now
and stuff it's not it's all you know
moonlight parasite very
you know um prestige fair it's you know
so
um
so we need we need it all i think we
need we need it all
do you think each
group has their own strong opinions
literary music film
and there's just so many
talking heads arguing about what's right
what's wrong
yeah i think i think because i think
everyone gets because everyone's passion
gets opinionated and everyone um feels
strongly about a a situation
maybe because i lived in a household
full of people where i always had to
listen to everyone first
and understand and i've always like
tried to be diplomatic in a lot of
different ways and that's helped but now
as you try to get you know in
more firm and more confident you have
you can't always please everyone you
have you you are going to do things for
yourself and sometimes that's going to
rub people wrong um so when you have all
these people whether it's in the music
that you know hey so-and-so is this so
oh you know this is like that um
uh
you know this work is too much like the
coen brothers or cone brother stink or
blah blah and that's that's great
everyone's entitled to their opinion and
that's the
the beauty of discourse i think what
happens is when the vitriol kind of kind
of gets the fire going um you know
i think that's that's that's that's the
thing when it becomes um
uh
personal but in terms of like
uh each industry i think everyone should
be passionate what they they root for
it's like sports like you got dallas
cowboy fans versus the steeler fans
everyone likes their thing you know um
so you pick your tribe and you push for
it and then uh you know
just you know some folks feel like they
need to be missionaries so
when you sit down to write a story do
you start with a treatment or an outline
now um each each
process has been a little bit different
for me for each one
uh
i've i've i've done quite a bit of um
one with treatments and outlines but
they're they're very
useful um but what i found more useful
is the the we talked about before the
movie days that's helped me give it give
it to give it a structure
but um
uh
i would come with idea and then
and sometimes
it depends on each each script sometimes
i'll let it flow and just kind of i'll
have an ending and i'll have a
image and we'll start from there
but then maybe one month later i'll
start an outline because i'm stuck
you know so um
but i like to be flexible on that in my
routine um just depending on
because some stories come out i think
it's like writing
i can only imagine if it's like writing
music some some songs you always hear
those great songs whether it's dolly
parton doing something like nine to five
in like two minutes or something like
that or like
or like someone oh i just walked into
the night and just wrote this master's
piece sometimes it pours out sometimes
it's laborious um
but again
um so i you know i think those are
useful treatments and not online so
definitely
that was a great movie too yeah
oh nine to five oh yeah yeah that's
great
with your film all roads to perla it
started with an idea from seeing a paper
bag or a plastic bag uh yeah well i had
an image
of that
i also had an image
of the texas landscape
um
and i had the feeling
of this wide open space
uh at night and and i knew that one of
the characters
was uh
a wrestler and during when your
wrestling season i used to wrestle
sometimes you would sleep
in a plastic bag
um and then i had these images of
plastic uh
you know there's a
plastic bag hanging in a tree sometimes
when you drive around
in the desert and things like that are
out out there you'll see that so it
started what with with the landscape
seeing plastic
and then having that feel
um
of then i thought of plastic bag body
bags
um then i thought
which was all because of daydreaming you
think you start your driving
your day well i told you not to drive
and daydream but i was on the road a lot
for for
my assignments
and
you're covering texas i covered like
five thousand miles in 21 days to do
like 18 shoots one time and that was
how
already superlast sort of coming out um
is because i saw all these
places and faces and i didn't want that
to end you know so i would just combine
them and create my own story
and were you doing a full loop around
texas the outskirts i did i've probably
i've probably seen more of texas and
texans i've been to eagle pass
brownsville on
midlands pecos
um
everything for just
all different types of assignments so
and that's that
that's why that landscape to me had so
much like mystery
so much history and and it was just like
wow this is this is unbelievable you
know it's like you hear stories of
you know cowboys and this but to
actually see that land
it was awesome you know and the people
and and the culture uh you can't yeah
i was definitely inspired by by that and
then
i did and then i was sent down to
houston to do
a story and then that tied in to what i
was doing and in houston there's this
two mile stretch
where
uh there are these massage parlors
illegal massage parlors and then i was
in um i got to go on a raid with sheriff
so i would i would have all these like
interesting
heavy assignments um whether it's
immigration to that to
exilery the um michael morton he was um
accused of killing his wife served uh
like 22 years in death row but later
found out that he didn't do it so
all these human interest stories i
i wanted to understand um
it you know what that was all about we
make these choices and sometimes those
choices aren't good enough and and then
we
um
we have to live with the consequences
good or bad so that's what happened in
my time driving around in texas
how did you feel let's say you get out
at a road stop
go to use the bathroom at an older gas
station or
you stop for a bite to eat at a cafe i
mean like
how was that
you're just interacting with
it's interesting being an asian american
enjoying this going around a different
like i think i went to the least
populated county once population like 10
or something like that um
uh
it's cool it's cool it's it's again
um
i felt like i was
uh
like
in in
in a movie all the time i felt like it
was
but it's real it's awesome it's uh the
people the culture again i keep talking
about that um but
when i would stop
it's sort of like
when you get so used to thinking what
could happen like if these laws could
talk who lived here 20 years ago 40
years ago what what family you know it's
the same thing what happened this
stop what happened this
single single family home who owned it
before so your brain just goes
all over the place and i think
um working as a photographer i was able
to catch it with one frame but now as
like you you could write you could write
these stories and just make it up you
know like oh
this is what happened
fred walked out the door
got hit by a truck
his son's out for revenge there okay now
let's have fun and let's spend next two
hours writing about that why
who was who hid in the truck was there a
motive
what fred do that other person you know
it's so
that's that's kind of neat and that
helps with if you daydream a lot because
then you just go oh what happens over
there well maybe fred you know had it
coming
well that's what the mayor said well the
sheriff is a lot don't you know just so
you can keep going it's fascinating
interesting
on being on the road you you i think
we're where we behave differently too if
for let's say i took a greyhound across
country one time as a kid and if you're
in your own car versus you're in you
know waiting in line at an airport or
something you and you just you're seeing
all these people and you're imagining
what their lives are like and they're
looking at you thinking the same thing
you know and it's just i don't know
we're just in a different mindset i
think when we travel even just
domestically
yeah when you're seeing like
you know i would walk when i was in new
york or anywhere even here and you walk
by so many people and you're just like i
wonder
i wonder what their are we ever going to
meet again then you're like i wonder how
many
photos i'm in in the background that you
know that i don't know of and things
like that
and you then you realize how many people
are in this world and then you realize
how many um
stories there are but then you're like
we're all human we have these same
emotions how do we tap on into that and
that's why when you hear music
and songs that could move
a whole country a whole world that is
amazing to have write something in three
minutes to have something play in three
minutes and it just moves everyone um
yeah mozart or anything like that elvis
elvis and and and
beatles so which means we're connected
in a certain way we're connected with
emotions
um so i think
when we travel
though we see different things
differently as different people
who are still connected with those human
emotions and things you know that's
that's what the fun part is as as a
creator so
um
i grew up
um and if uh from i'm from laos my
grandmother
um came to the states in 1986 she didn't
know any english
so
and my allow is
not
great the greatest so it's
for us to communicate was
there's other other ways maybe that's
why i like filmmaking or or photography
it was other ways to communicate there's
were like
she would i would try to have to
translate general hospital to her and
why luke and laura got married and
things like that in lao and it was funny
so when you when you with another
language and you got to find other ways
to communicate maybe that i got so into
visuals into into sounds so those are
things that could express things versus
literally i am sad
you know i'm telling you i'm sad versus
like
uh a frown you know so that kind of
stuff so it's it's it's neat
is it important for you to know the
ending before you start writing your
screenplays
i mean
i would love to i would love to know the
inning all the time it'll be awesome
sometimes i have it and sometimes it
changes
i would love to know
as many parts of the puzzle
as i can
sometimes you discover it and it goes
another way and
i think
that's the beauty of
of sitting down and chipping things away
because it might make more sense
uh a lot of times it anchors things and
having an ending where you're
concrete about it um
helps you know
uh and so
but then you might fall in love with the
characters and you don't want you don't
want it to end that way so um
you know again trying to be flexible
with that is good in my opinion but
having it knowing the ending would be
awesome and sometimes i i have that in
my head
um
and then uh
and then you you play around with the
themes and then you follow the themes
and hopefully you could direct direct
everything towards the end you know so
that would be my process i don't know it
works all the time
but as a rule that sounds like you don't
always have to to know the ending before
you begin something
yeah i think so i think so um
it would be very helpful and it will
just guide and help guide
but um
i think you have a gist of your story
and then if you have that just then you
probably could get to the ending
you know
um quicker than you if you don't have
that
with all roads to perla did you know the
ending
as you begin
i had an idea of an ending now knowing
how to tie it all up
it took me a while
um
i remember i did have like i know how i
wanted to end
but how it what but how how it ended um
was still up in the air because there
were so many loose parts um i think
one of the things that i found even with
the script in the early stages
is i don't know if anyone out there has
a
similar problem your story lines
sometimes
it has to you got to wrangle them back
and and have that fit
on
it
and that that was the trick tricky part
you know
and not make it seem so forced and
things and massage it correctly and um
and get still get your message across
or you know what the story's about so
yeah um when i started i had an idea
what's gonna happen
um
but uh you know without giving anything
away it
it it was it guided
but the little details was harder you
know
maybe help me understand that so is it
almost like if you're gonna search for
halloween decorations but then you go
down this rabbit hole and now you're
searching
fall you know you're going and then
you're like you know what wait my
original plan was to look for halloween
decorations is that so we're talking
about where you go you have to wrangle
it back in
yeah like like let's say for instance i
had
um we had skeletons we had zombies and
we had you know we have ghosts
uh
but only the ghost is at the end
you know
what happened to the skeleton and the
zombies
without it becoming
did we forget him at the aisle 14 or you
know like or did it or did they
disappear or did the ghost take it you
know so
if you knew that the ghost is
the one that's there
at the end because you just you don't
you you know in the front yard
then maybe you want the zombies in the
back
later you know you know you know you
have the elements but you know you
thought like you wanted the ghost to be
the one that is the main highlight um i
think that's what i'm kind of talking
about more like i have an idea i want
the ghost to be my the guy out there but
how do i what i do with the rest of the
crew i mean that interesting okay
and and do do we really need to know how
much and why you've left
the skeleton in the aisle 4 or 14
whatever
that goes back to
our discussion of do you want to hand
hold more or do you want to
leave it leave it on
leave it leave it a little bit more
obscure you know so do we leave a foot
out then you see the skeleton foot in
aisle 14 or do you want the entire leg
out or do you want the entire body out
so you could see that he that skeleton
got killed at aisle 14 you know that
kind of stuff so that's the that's
what's i think what i'm talking about in
terms of like have an ending i have a
feeling ending how do i get there
with all these other other things that
are happening but then sometimes you go
you know what
actually
the skeleton should be the one that's at
the end
you know that so that could happen you
know but with all rose and perrla i had
it i had a
feeling what i wanted
uh my challenge was
like
i know i knew the last page
my challenge was the five pages prior to
that last page
you know that kind of thing
of you know tying things up and
getting it right and who's and how do we
get there to make it kind of you know
dramatic and
um
suspenseful things like that
and how long did it take you to write
the full script the first draft i
started it like
10 10 years ago
the first uh
um
maybe a good
good draft afterwards maybe like
eight months
eight months or so
and then rewrite rewrite rewrite more
of of it so
i can't even remember now it's like so
so so kind of like
long ago but i do remember when i was
starting it because i was like i'm gonna
try to write my you know i wrote one
feature
i was like i'm gonna do this this one
and then
i got stuck and i took one character and
wrote a short film on it and that short
film became my first short film
called balloons go pop um
of it so
um i i used it as a a way to kind of
like
have a uh sort of like a sounding board
i i didn't have the pressure of like oh
i need to finish it in six months or
nine months i was just going through
exercises of it
and trying to
figure my way out even
dialogue even
um all the all the elements of
screenwriting so
i was trying to
just get better at it
and then that over time
i went back to the story and shaped it
up um until i felt confident
that there was something there
and that was a 10-year process
from script to screen
from script to final
shooting draft probably
six
five
five six years yeah
okay so you knew at that point then this
is something i'm committed to if this
story still interests me
that many years later i think so if you
ask my wife and i think i was so stupid
i was like hey if i die could you make
this film please it's so dumb i don't
know i just got so like
i don't know i
i don't even know why it's just like i
just wanted
to finish you know i i just wanted to
finish it
um
because it took
so much to get it going and then i just
didn't want it to sit in my drawer or
sit in my laptop
so
you know i i
i enjoyed the characters and i just
wanted to kind of see it come alive and
again that's a selfish thing
to oh i wrote something i wanted to see
it come alive that kind of thing and
and and that's what i was driven at
because like i said um
i love to quit things when when when it
doesn't feel right and this never not
felt right so i just kept going and
going um
and even though
there are multiple many moments of of
you know it's brutal it's so it's a
brutal thing and i i want to kind of
and not say there's a myth of of things
there's a brutal stretch of each of each
of the process
to get it done how
what are you doing with your life how's
this happening
how's the finance going how are you
going to make grant where are you going
to do this how what if you don't get to
this festival what does this distribute
you know all these kinds of weird things
that
you don't think about when you first
start writing
and going oh
fade in
you don't think then we're like oh it
just leads you on so uh the journey has
been
um
quite quite interesting
and uh you know but sometimes when you
see these things you all see some person
awesome they have a movie and austin
they get another movie and all this and
it just so happens because i was there
and going how did this happen you know i
was like
but my thought was if someone else can
do it let me deconstruct this
i could figure this out and do it so
my only thing is
just trying to figure it out how to do
it
so it's like
um i found one side of the rubik's cube
that's that's what happened and
um here we are just you know
ready sadistically enough ready to try
to do another one so
there you have it
is it really that selfish though to want
to make it i mean
going back to we talked about it's also
selfish to want to be promoted in
corporate america so yeah it's really
selfish um
maybe that's me just kind of like
make me feel better uh because because
in the end it is a lot of like
trying to you know
play to your ego play ego
your own ego and and and figuring out
and and going why do you want to do this
you know
i cuz i think it's a very honest
question to ask yourself
in the mirror
why do you want to do this
um
it's almost because
that's all you kind of
want to do and maybe
feel like you're somewhat good at
um
not because if someone's telling you
that you're good at it is because you
feel
that it feels like you're good at it you
know it's it's hard because it's like
people try you try to enter competitions
and you try to do this and get
validated and serve in different ways
i think i got so
rejected so many times that i i didn't
want i was like screw validation i love
doing it
i'm going to keep doing it you know it's
like
but
what was that what does that entail
um
and when is it when is it enough so i'm
still trying to figure that out you know
as i go and one isn't enough
when do do i have to write how many
scripts do i have to write you know how
many um
movies that
would would i
will make me happy so then i'll be like
hmm
it's again just trying to make a
sustainable career
um
that's just to go my goal so
uh that's where i am at this point and
and trying to um sometimes it's a curse
because you're like
you know
you wish i i wish i would have gotten
for that that fourth more rejection to
go okay now i'm becoming a marketing
assistant or something like that and
you're like ah that would be so much
easier gosh but now you're just like why
am i cursed to kind of
put myself in
you know people i love in this this kind
of like brutal
um
uh kind of journey of filmmaking you
know
but then
it's a privilege
situation
to cry about creating so
being off camera as we were taking a
quick break you said something about
possibly why why not just do this as a
hobby filmmaking screenwriting
yeah
yeah i know you know
you know
i ask myself that every day it's like
sometimes it's it's it's just easier or
more precious when you keep something to
yourself as a hobby you know it's like
this
going at it and going making it a living
it's you know it's not all 100 being
creative it's you know like it's
85 business 15
being creative and and you have to um be
okay with that you know sometimes
and that
and that is the the trick that that
could lead to that cynicism you know and
like and and and things that
that happened so
what
you know so i asked huh
i should just keep writing because i
enjoy it but what's that need you know
what's that need so
um yeah i asked myself that every day
um
sometimes i wish it was a hobby but i'm
too stubborn and too
uh
you know
crazy to um
that lets sleeping a sleeping dog lie or
something like that so uh
i keep pushing ahead
can you describe your typical writing
day
yeah
so i said i i find that
i get
a lot of good stuff down
earlier my brain just is more lucid i
think
because it's it maybe is because i'm
coming off of like a
um
sleep so six
seven six seven to nine
a.m is where i think i write my write my
best um that's me personally and
uh
i'll just tackle
tackle that and try to write some days i
some days
um i could get four pages some days i'll
get half a page but when i'm finishing
up a script um
i write till like
two or three from that more so try to
get a good eight hour get eight hours
and sometimes i'll stare at the page or
i'm researching
or on on talking things out or writing
at but when i'm finished working on a
script i i
i try to do that a good amount like good
study mount each day
um
the rewrites
uh when i'm doing rewrites so after
just
um recently
we are
we just did a read through so we'll have
it read through to see how it sounds uh
because sometimes when you read a script
you read it faster or slower so when you
have someone who just reads it out
you can get a better time if it's the
scenes too long if everyone's twitting
their thumb and going like hey let's
wrap this up that's when we
you could tell we want to cut it cut it
up more make it
faster so we'll do a read through
and then um we'll have notes and then
i'll go through
wake up
and
send some emails but then i'll go
through the notes and and and knock
knock it out you know and go hey uh this
we need to add a little more humor here
or hey we got to do this or cut this out
or
um
this is a three-page scene
we need to you know trim it down
so i would work those angles so um
again
uh the earlier the better for me so i
could you know it doesn't seem like um
my brain works a little bit better that
way
when you do the read through or you have
someone else do it are they reading with
no emotion
yeah they're just reading it through so
they don't have to act it out they could
just you know read scene headings seeing
this and sometimes they you know they'll
get into an act but they don't have to
be it doesn't have to be like a table
read of everything but just go
interior
um jacob's kitchen
so and so it comes in you know then and
they're they'll just read it normal yeah
so so we could see the pacing and then
if there's a
issue where they want to go it's like
hey
does he really have does he really say
yes ma'am right now he said it three yes
ma'am
three three three you know pages ago or
something i don't think he's going to
say yes ma'am now so you could really
kind of
work on dialogue too and that it just
sounds a little bit off or forced you
know so it every everyone would have
like an idea and me as a writer i'll
take the notes and go um
you know and that helps that helps
because
when you when you guys are
reading in your head
sometimes you get stuck you know so it's
nice to kind of hear it hear the words
out it doesn't have to be acted out but
the but that'll give you a better time
frame
um
so i recommend that if you get even a
friend after you finish something having
to read through um
it took
the last read through it took us about
we started 11 and finished at like four
you know because you're going through
each word each page each word
leave a stop you know and go oh what do
you think about that you know things
like that so that really helped
there's a new
new job description in the pandemic yeah
yeah have a job as a reader yeah just
read it through on zoom or something
yeah absolutely nice because um
you know
it's better to have someone versus a
writer read it or you know director so
you could sit there
have your team of collaborators a
producer director whoever and so they
could hear it and hear it out
once you start writing a screenplay how
often do you
write how often do you go to write it so
page one
of something you're getting up at six in
the morning maybe
you're
excited and then maybe you're stopping
at 9am depending on your schedule and
then how often are you going back to it
during the day
um
during the course of however long it
takes you to finish so whether it's a
year 10 years
i just did i just finished uh one
it took me about four
months
and i spent
every day
pretty much at it for about
average of like four to five hours a day
on it so
um
that one yeah so it depends like i said
the always the perla look how long it
took but now as you get better and
you're more confident of
of
of what you want and the structure of
the scenes and things like that and um
i had in my head of like
what stephen king always says of like
you don't wait for inspiration you just
get to work you know so even if i'm
staring at the page or something
i'm
zoned in i'm
focusing on it so i i wanted to kind of
just keep chiseling it um
and and sometimes you get great
breakthroughs you know and you'll write
a good amount
but um
it's it's it's different for each one
for the last couple months i'll be
disciplined on that like um i just try
to treat myself like a like an athlete
if i had to go do this for if in a day
what would so and so i hear you know
let's say like
i just read something that was just on
jimmy butler from miami he gets he said
he was up at three or four a.m
practicing or something like that so i
wanted to implement those kind of like
um practices they always say like um i i
try to do things that
that
that you don't want to do
because
they're usually good for you and then so
it's like i don't want to wake up every
day and do this but
um
but if you love it and if you're
challenged by it it's it's not that
painful um so uh i'm fortunate to kind
of go
oh awesome um you know i'm gonna work on
on this um meanwhile we're also trying
to run um
you know commercials and things like
that so you have to balance kind of
different things and stuff and and doing
that and you might not have
um
uh certain weeks where you can but i'll
try at least slide something in maybe in
it
maybe it's 2 a.m to 4
4 you know afterwards um but at least
i'll try to put the hours in um
for for writing yeah
well so you're up writing
occasionally at 2 a.m
yeah sometimes yeah sometimes yeah
because you're like
you're just so
um
you're just so kind of
addicted to it because like you know
you're in the cut if you're just in the
cusp of breaking through the scene
you know and just get it out and then
you can come back later and elevate it
you know and and just and texturize it
and do this but
but you're in a role you know like if
you keep getting rolls
then you'll get to that 90 page 100 page
and you're like ah i'm finished and let
it sit and now you could work on the
rewrite
afterwards
does writing energize you or exhaust you
both they they just kind of like hit you
and
um
you know
i get really excited
when um i could create that world that
gets me really excited when i get the
characters alive
it exhausts me because i want it to go
faster than
than what where it's going um i you know
you want it sounds like christmas you
want christmas to come right away you
want to just tear through the
presents but it's um
you know and and you you come in on all
sorts of problems and you just wish that
you could figure it out right away and
sometimes you need that break though
it's like how come i didn't think about
it yesterday but today is so clear this
is what has to happen and and
that that's exciting when i get that
it's frustrating when i couldn't think
about it that day you know
the answer to that you know
that question oh like oh that's a great
line that leads to this or you know or
maybe i should add this
action to it um
so
it does energize me but it's definitely
frustrating
what is the most difficult part of the
writing process for you
yeah i like to always try to be like
honest of of the
the
ability
of what i can do and you know you strive
to be the best you can
and uh
like
i think the most difficult part is
because you want it to be so good
you're trying to figure out ways and
there's so many elements to that
is it this it's the story it's the
dialogue it's it's the characters um and
how that all fits in it's putting it all
together it's
the difficult part is to make
each scene
so good
that there is no bad scene
so if there is a bad scene you have to
get that scene out
so that how do we get it everything's so
good that's and that's the tough that's
that's what we're all trying to figure
out right how do we get the reader to
turn the page to keep turning the page
it's when it gets boring when it's when
only gets
you know not interesting when there's
not a voice when the characters are
doing the same thing we've seen this
it's so
so it's hard to find that creativity
that juice to kind of
you might have one great scene but then
the other three are like average how do
i get those other three from a three to
a five you know how do i get get it to a
five and that's the frustrating part
like dang is it the story or dang is it
the character itself or is it my stupid
dialogue you know it's like
that's the heart the hardest part of it
all the frustrating part um and that's
what keeps you going because you know
you got one good scene it keeps you know
you're asking about what energizes oh
man that was great it felt good it was
gone then then the next scene it comes
to the dead hold and like stop and like
what did i just write you know it makes
no sense it's boring it's it's cliche
it's now or never it's i love you you
know versus you know it's easy to say
like show it show it on screen show the
thing but to actually do it is that's
the craft and beauty of
what all these great screenwriters are
trying to do you know and it's like you
see michael jordan shooting
the basketball but you don't see him
all those years of practice so
so um
you know we just try to
get to work and
craft the scene as best as we can
and get better at it and and then finish
the story and hop on into the next one
did you watch last dance i did yeah yeah
that's nice it's really fascinating yeah
behind you know i always
yeah i love seeing everyone's process of
of how to do things right
right especially someone who's very
tenacious and
always wants to you know and knows that
that's something in him that
he almost can't stop himself yeah
yeah so
you know
it's
so you could have it you could have a
talent you could have all that you could
have a lot of different things but i
think what's
hard to teach is that obsessiveness
you know
why do you want to wake up it's easy to
sleep you know easy to put it off to the
next day
um
so
but you know because of the pandemic and
stuff we are we're all going through
those questions
what
you know like of of of things what's
important what do we want to do what do
we want to accomplish how much time do
we have things like that i think
for me
it was you know
i you know i made a decision i mean i
lost my mom through
breast cancer uh
15 years ago
so that was the launch
of me going
um
i'm just gonna try it
and and
try
try something
that um you know i don't know what's
gonna happen
because it's easy to try things when you
know what's gonna happen
and uh
still you know so i was like i think
being with her for those last couple
months of just trying to go like
and giving her saying go ahead it was
just i was like oh my gosh i could
go ahead and you know
go ahead really you were you know
i never had that kind of freedom from a
parent her especially her because she
wanted me to um
you know
uh do other things
but but then she finally knew and i i
loved that i was like i'm going to take
this and run and see how far i could get
you know so
that's uh
that's what kind of
helped start it all no you know
so
my sort of pandemic hit 15 years ago of
going like
oh
we're not giving tomorrow you know and i
i'm gonna try as hard to get better each
day because i like doing it you know um
i'm not gonna waste time i'm not gonna
waste a year if i'm in a job that i
didn't like because i i'm not guaranteed
next year i kept that in my head so
that's why i had this thing about time
um just because of my mom
and so that that helped me kind of like
appreciate time and appreciate good and
bad things you know it's not to say i
want
to have
everything being great but it's just i
want to live life
you know i want to experience it all i
just don't want to waste time being
unhappy
i'd like to be unhappy because i could
feel i just want to spend two years on
it you know
sometimes i feel like i'm living for two
people you know so you want to
experience everything and you want it
it's it's just as simple as going
outside or taking the trash out so all
the things that
i would convince myself i
um
that are you know hard or
because i'm lazy or i was like even
doing that i should just be grateful for
you know going walking outside doing
this so if i have an opportunity to
write a script um that's luxurious so
i'm gonna i'm gonna swing for the fences
because
you know
not given
uh
tomorrow pretty much
with your screenwriting van do you try
to be original or do you try to give the
audience what you think they would want
i think uh
i try to come up the original concept
and and uh you want to start out with
that and because that sort of what what
drives you i know you suppose i know
they say hey think about what what the
audience is they think about your
audience what's your genre who's
watching this who's doing that but i
think you just start writing the story
that motivates you um
and and what gets you through you know
because you're gonna
if you're gonna have to live with this
for a long time in terms of like
producing it or in terms of writing it
and then if you go on to try to get it
produced and made it has to be
um something that that
that you're proud of or that you want to
you know go through that
journey with so
um if that idea
is an original idea for you and and at
least it's for me i start with that so
all the scripts that i have
on written is is
is basically
um
from
original thoughts and not i don't even
think about
the budget and stuff like that maybe
because
the stories i write just tend to you
know fall in the same thing but
you know it's not super high concept
it's not out in space it's not this it's
just like
grounded in what's happening here in
humanity but but um
when i start out something like i come
it from a original perspective
do you think you could be okay with
being a writer for hire or something
where
it may not be your
style and maybe two hand-holding of a of
a story
but you're being sort of like okay paid
to do it
even though it might not be something
you would want to watch would you have
trouble with that um
this is like me going through like if
i'm actually writing sticking to the
themes
my original thought of all this was to
have a sustainable career
so
to answer that yeah i would do it i'm
not a young buck coming out at 25 years
old and having the luxury of a lot of
time time and doing this but
i think the more you can do anything
the better you get get at it you know um
you know you always hear now i start to
understand
why
people might complain why actors take
certain roles and things like that
you know no one can't everyone can't be
daniel day-lewis and do these
maybe you just want to
be a role that's goofy and fun
maybe i want to
test my chops on
something
different from i'm not you know we
talked about athletes and stuff
you want to come back to each season
with new things that you learn
everything you know whether if i ever
get a chance at a studio
world
writing something that's you know that
i'm gonna learn something from that you
could always take that back
and then i could always do it as a hobby
my own stuff later you know that kind of
stuff so things like that i'm still not
opposed to that um
if if that is an opportunity uh
or you know i'm not one of those i'm
going to be not tour and everything
that's going to happen
just trying to take it one one film at a
time if it happens
they'll be i think that would be um
a good problem to have to make that
decision
i always wonder about like
actors who get these commercials where
they become these spokespersons for like
well over a decade
and and how do they feel about that i
mean if it if it provides a nice
lifestyle for someone and they feel a
sense of satisfaction
maybe they weren't the leading role on
general hospital or something but
you know it was always but then some
people go to the sellout term
and i think that would be
i think most of us would probably
they'd go with the steady paycheck yeah
you know
we think percentage-wise of things and
me you want you know how many like you
said how many of us can can be paul
thomas anderson or quentin tarantino
how many people are even behind the
scenes doing stuff that we don't even
know about that no one does that has to
punch up a script or do this or do
whatever you ha you have
but if you're in in it um
it
it beats um
other things so
like you know
you know definitely it would be
something that's now it's not like
something you always
want to do and
you want to build leverage but also you
want to be working
you know
nothing wrong with them no no no no not
that
how has all rhodes de perla changed your
writing process
i think
um since it's one of the earlier ones
and and and
and seeing
how it could be developed and into it um
i think now i'm trying to get tighter in
my storytelling um
you know you're trying to if again back
to an athlete uh analogy an athlete what
could you work on i think it's um for
writing for
uh
film i i need to be tighter for 90
minutes
for hours to perla
and other things i think there's a world
where you can have it like episodic
limited series so you could
dive into the characters more you know
on in
uh
i think that's that's what i've kind of
learned if i have a if i have a
situation or an idea that involves tons
of characters
i probably would
start out writing it as a pilot
and
now if i have like a pretty
great
um idea that i could tell within
a film space of like 90 minutes
um
i'll switch the film i think that's
that's how
riding that all roads superior has
helped me kind of kind of divide the the
two areas i believe
just to
keep them separate
because each one has its own sort of uh
you know um
format and and expectations
when you say tighter do you mean that
you feel sometimes the story will
meander
and you're trying to keep it on course
yeah yeah i think um for me personally i
think because i write
very visually um
i think it's too flowery and i write as
a writer director
so
there's a lot of things i'm putting on
the page that that um
i don't need to
because i know i'm going to direct it
but i like to write it and create it for
for folks but if i was purely
writing as a writer i get supe a lot
tighter
um because i i want to experience that
in terms of like
not to be you know
to explain things and not have as much
you know
camera direction or setting things up
and flowery i want it tighter so i won't
so i could turn the page
that would be my goal now before i think
the goal before was
um writing something with with heart now
i think um
maintaining that
but
but condensed
yeah
van if we were going to get a seven
minute lesson from you on writing a
screenplay so i've never written a
screenplay before but i had this movie
idea
can you
help me write that screenplay
in seven minutes
not the actual screenplay
instruct me on um
man i you know
i'm not one an authority but
if i had to if someone
if i was asking myself that when i was
starting
what would would i say to my
younger self um in seven minutes how to
start this um
what i would i would first off see
what's the story what's what's the genre
and
why do you want to tell it
in three words give me three words about
the story it could be just three three
words
revenge
um another word so we'll start with
those words then give me a character
who do you want in the character
then i'll go
ask okay
where's this take place
um get the character
what's the character's job what does
that person do
and what does that character want to do
and then
develop the world
develop the character
and why do you want to tell that story
and we'll start from there and then go
out go back and then just even if it's
one page or two page
or three pages um
write something about what this
character does in that world with their
job and when what what they want to do
and then once you have that then we
could flesh it out a little bit more and
then then maybe
like you said start an outline
um what what what do they need what's
their obstacles um
and
and then we add more characters in but i
i would probably start with
um who the who the main character is and
um
in the world they're in
so then just quickly i'll give you my
character is a waitress
at a greasy spoon diner
off
route whatever in texas okay
she's 40.
she makes decent wages there it's not
really an exciting job
but
the owner of a local plant
has said i will make a deal with you
and that deal is i want you to listen to
what my employees say when i'm not there
and you're going to report back and i'm
going to put you on payroll
okay
all right it seems like there's a lot of
conflict there's some sort of like moral
uh you know dilemma as well and you got
a character
on
and then what and then you could explore
explore that explore the routes of is
she
a good
hearted waitress
is she does she want to
become the owner of this
take out the boss or does she want to
fight for who's who's doing
who um they're listening into
um
so there's different routes in that so
it starts to what's what's the
the the
the makeup of this
or our hero or or protagonist because
they could be like the joker he's you
know he you didn't have to be the best
guy
but um
what was this person doing and so at
least you have you have that and you
have that to start and then
um
and then throw throw a couple obstacles
and then and see what happens you know
uh
because it could lead somewhere else
because you're just you just have an
idea you don't have it yet formed so run
with it run with something run with a
direction and maybe write it
and then that might spur
spur something forward
hence time back to the daydreaming
because you don't know
what it could lead because you're saying
oh
actually she's doing this because she
wants to get to new york and because you
know why because she she um
her uh
you know um
she gave up a daughter
and now that she wants to you know she
wants to go see that because she only
has six months left to live and she
wants to make peace with that daughter
and and tell her things that she she
wished that someone told her
something like that so
that's just that's the association
disconnect and you could go okay is that
the story you want to tell or
you know or do you want a a
you know a drama or do you want it a um
a genre or a horror film so so you stick
stick to that and that that's where
it'll lead and what was the last part
i'm asking myself why do i want to write
this yeah why why i think you should all
also ask why
why do you want to write this
what like
it's a question where because it's going
to drop drive the narrative because
um it's
that that's the question and the answer
is your your screenplay because it's
it's i think
there's something in that film that you
crown you create that you're trying to
investigate so why do you want to write
this what's going on are you trying to
talk about
unrequited love are you going to try to
talk about um
you know
haunted pass or you're going to try to
talk about you know
what a new way out a new living you know
hope and things like that so why do you
want to talk about that and it generally
has to do sometimes what's happening in
your life you know right now and it's
because it's easier to because you could
feel like oh i feel like i want to talk
about anxiety the loss of jobs the the
loss of the economy being a new
homeowner not knowing if i can make that
how can i synthesize that feeling into
the script of this girl in the diner how
to get that feeling anxiety
in there what she's going through you
know so that's
how it would kind of
help usher it along and then just write
your first draft and
come with an image you already got the
image diner maybe the opening shot is a
bottle of ketchup who knows and it falls
on the floor and she picks it up and
sweeps it away
and then that could be an image a theme
that could that you could hold on to
throughout um
you know sparingly
so you're not totally spoon feeding the
audience of why is that a ketchup
is she part of the hunts family who
knows you know
do i know the ending
do i need to know it
what if you write three endings
put in a hat and pick one
and then
and go from there
so if a lot of times i think for me i
have problems deciding
so
if there's a course already set
and you know you have a couple of
different things
you could try it but then if it's a
course you don't like
you revere back sort of like maybe
that's what i do in my life it's like
i'll try it if i don't like it i'll veer
back you know so that's sort of like
that process of me for writing i'll go
down on the road
oh my gosh that dialect's too cheesy i
don't need that character i don't need
to talk to the other waitress i needed
to talk to the mailman that came and
gave her a package that came from new
york
or something like that you know
so then the three alternate endings
could be
she makes her money she leaves that town
she doesn't look back she sees her
daughter
she tells her i'm sorry
she has a sense of peace the daughter
has a sense of peace the other ending
could be
she meets a good looking drifter
and he's a smooth talker
and he says darling i want to take you
to new york
i want to see mama meet her baby
and
they go she packs
he says hang on i'm going to get smokes
at this gas station he robs it she
doesn't know that she's in the car now
she's an accomplice
he gets arrested she gets arrested she
goes to prison
she dies there
third
she's too scared to go
the daughter says i don't don't come
[Music]
and she ends up staying at this diner
and um
nothing much happens to her and she just
kind of stews in the
regret yeah those are great great
great three things see
so
with even with that we just spit bald in
two three minutes
and just write it
a lot of times
we'll just sit there and wait for two
months or three months no this is not
working i gotta research this i gotta do
that but if you stick to those feelings
i'm already thinking about the girl oh
what if she came
to the diner finally and then you know
like and just different things so that's
what happened that's sort of what
happens and you kind of like
go with it but you never know where it
goes unless um you try it so
yeah that's good if she shows up yeah
that's it right
why'd you give me up you know
right then you have that
awesome
or it could be really like that
you know
scene from the rest of the wrestler when
when she she uh the daughter comes and
talks to mickey roark and that powerful
exchange of like oh you know things like
that so why
or it could be a thriller that she comes
back and
poisons her
oh gosh
yeah
i like it now i want to write this thing
that's good that helped i like to
throwing the three things in there and
then some of the other ideas i wouldn't
have thought about the daughter in new
york no you don't that's
that's the
so
now when you do that when you
that's the fun part when you start then
you
read it out loud you're like oh things
open up you know like so that's why i
think it's important to
not be holding to what you've done
you know because
it's like
you should feel really good that you've
already wrote it it's out there
but if that scene needs to go
it needs to go and a new one could be
born that's that's the whole thing and
not be so precious with with these
scenes because
um
i think that's i think that's the scary
part because you well at least for me
i'll talk about me again
sometimes you feel like you can't do it
like it won't be as good or just it
won't work or it's
you haven't thought about it you know
because it takes a lot of work you know
yeah and you brought up stuff that i
wasn't thinking of and so and then i
liked it better you know what you
brought up and and and you brainstorm
yeah
what's the title of this
of
the
um let's see i love titles um that's the
hardest that's
that's one that kind of
what do you what do you feel the title
should be
waiting
i'm that might be too cliche
sorry but it's also
it's not just what she does but her
daughter is waiting for an answer
yeah she's waiting to start her life
so as cliche as it sounds there's many
meanings to that
yeah i probably would
it takes me longer with the with the
title because that would that's sort of
what would drop would
drive it um could be
you know
is it more about the daughter or the mom
good question so
you know
right i think it's more about the mom
yeah so
so
pick her middle name
and then jolene
she's a southern gal she's a southern
belle
maybe she won a beauty contest when she
was younger but she got stuck in this
town
and jolene sounds great yeah
yeah i think that's a good sounding name
or you could and then you could add um
or you could as you as you go um
maybe it's a letter that the uh
a phrase a letter that she she had
slipped for the baby whenever she had or
something like that
or maybe
maybe it's both of their names
jolene and uh
jolene and izzy
you know i like that
so maybe it's about both of them so you
and then you couple them up
like them louise
and you have them drive off the cliff
sure and then there's a brad pitt
character too yeah gotta have that one
you gotta have that
and a dancing scene every great movie
has a dance that's true yeah and every
80s movie had a great singing scene
you've mentioned previously reading a
lot of screenplays where do you find the
screenplays that you read i
whether it's on on the internet and you
just kind of like
um
you know look for it those are like
established like uh
like screen screen plays where it's like
being in las vegas or
or um
you know
movies that are coming out for for
oscars because they would release it by
the studios or things like that or the
blacklist
announcements will have that i also have
worked with a development for
finland entertainment and where i would
cover lots of different screenplays so i
get to see
and read tons
that aren't they're not produced yet and
things like that so you kind of you kind
of get a uh
a a good or i kind of get a good uh
grasp of what's what's being out there
and
what's been done when you re you know
read your favorite screenplays and and
watch the movies and i think that's
that's a good start
do you watch the movies first or read
the screenplay first or it varies i
think it varies but some sometimes i i
prefer the screen the screenplays um
because i like to have my own
interpretations of that but there are
some
like
um
that i've read that
are just really spot on but i love i
love reading screenplays um it just kind
of flows and you could
you read enough of them i guess you
could feel
uh you could really tell the writer's
voice it's it's it's cool when you do
when you do and you see that and like oh
wow
you know that really flows and the way
they use alliteration or there's ways
they use their periods or how they space
stuff or how
all these little things um
because there's not not much else but
the way you move it is
is how you know it's pretty vital i
think that's the craft of it and
and being economical in terms of
describing things and and
and you know it's so true i keep going
back these cliches of like
arrive late and leave early you know
that kind of stuff um that you always
hear and it's it's
it's hard to do when you're you're
you're kind of in that world in focus so
that's why it's good to just get that
first draft done and then just cut
chopping you know and you feel you if
you miss it and then add it back in you
know
do you ever read non-professional
screenplays
yeah yeah yeah i think i mean
not as much as recently of of things um
but uh
i've read you know just different
friends and things like that or
last couple years not as much though a
lot have been um just from you know
what's out there
um
so
to answer that question i haven't to be
honest i haven't read many
non-professional screenplays last like
three years or so yeah
what's the difference between an amateur
script and a professional script
they say it's like the first
couple pages and um
it's the command of that page the way
you
intro a character the way
the world is created the way that um
you turn the page that that's it i don't
know how like um
when you read something
that
makes you want to get up and go to put
the
popcorn in the microwave or go make a
toast
that happens with professional
screenplays too there's a lot it's hard
it's hard to keep someone engaged
for
how many like an hour and a half to read
if we read that thing so the difference
i would say
is how
how they get into the characters build
that world
and um
and have
unique voices
and make you want want to care on the
page that you could feel
you could see the movie in your head you
know i think that's that's the thing
you've seen something that you've
that you haven't before
versus like oh this reminds me of that
or this oh this reminds me of um
you know forrest gump but i think uh
when we first started on that fault of
it too is because we don't we we're tr
we're being influenced and
and being inspired by the things that we
like and we come it comes into our work
but that's why if you stick to the
themes you stick to how you express
those
i think you can have something more
original because it's your voice it's
connected to you personally
um so
that's the answer it's being personal
because it's something personal to this
individual
that i'm i want to experience that i see
it on the page yeah
and is that going back to what we talked
about earlier is finding the why
yeah i think so yeah why you know it's
like hey why do i want to
to
to write this because
there's layers of stuff even if it's um
an allegory to this or parallels it's
it's a lot of different things even if
it's about space martians or even it's a
fast and furious there's other things
involved you know um why why
and then when you when when you actually
read something
um that drives you
it's because that person
has has
has made
uh these characters come alive you know
and you you want to know what's going to
happen
um
so i think that's
that's the difference because
it's hard to explain i guess but when
you read it you're like oh
i'm gonna go make coffee instead versus
like when you read something like wait a
second
i'm gonna read that if you guys are ever
like um
back even
i took like a lot of english classes
even though i was a business major i was
too lazy to change
um
majors
but i remember reading jude the obscure
cut all day thomas hardy booked like
just couldn't put it down it took me a
couple days but i couldn't stop now
imagine a script
which is 100 pages so
that's
that's the aim and the goal um to have
to write something that someone can't
put down um
not everyone and when there's going to
be a lot of people that hate it a lot of
people love it but there will be a
person that's going to love it and can't
put that down that's that's the kind of
that's the goal i think
all right judy bloom books yeah yeah
couldn't just turn down they were all
excellent yeah definitely
how do you work with actors and actually
more specifically how does your process
working with actors evolve from the
audition to them working with them on
set
yeah great um
that's that's fun part working with
actors they're they're
i mean actors so talented they
you want to create um
opportunities for them
to perform at their highest level
and
from for our for our purposes for all
roads of perla
um we you know there's no rehearsals
they just can't they come and just nail
it you know it's just just the way just
how how they are
um
but each one is each actor is different
you know it's like being a coach again
from a team each player is motivated in
certain ways each character is
developing certain things your
my job as a director for me
is to provide them a place to try things
to to get into that character and to
elevate what's on
on that script
um
and i think that
that's the key to to have them add
their special sauce to this
dish
because
even if
the way someone says two words
by the way their eyes twitch
could say a lot and it's because they're
feeling that character and that they're
not walking
through they're not just dialed in
because
i
that's what makes them great you know
it's versus um
someone who's reading lines you could
feel
that's that's their gift to to perform
and make that character
uh emote
um so as a writer you try to give them
the words to do that but as a performer
and as a director
i just get out of the way
and go hey let's take another take
i know it's so easy hey try this
it's a matter of having you know a
director's that job is
you know it's like it's a taste you
direct things you say this but
you just got to give the actor that that
that
luxury
you know um
some people need
something to hold some people need this
so you have to know what each actor
needs
and give that to them you know
so
um from audition to screen
again
i was lucky to
be working with stellar actors for the
first time professional actors who
who
have been doing this for years you know
addison's was his she's was acting for
decades dash my hock decades
so
it's me just
for them to love the script and and run
with it and that's the that's the key
you know get that script so they they um
they feel like they could add something
to it
so the delivery of lines little
facial micro expression
[Music]
exactly something twitch in the eye
twitch
and here's the best part that they do it
over and over again the exact same way
so when you edit it's almost seamless
that's a professional you know that's
what they're giving you
that that opportunity in the edit room
to use takes that are just great
but they do it in a way where it's just
not like my hair is blown this way or
this hair this or the shirt or um
things and just that professionalism and
understanding um
what the character needs but then just
delivering in that you know
in a hot room but no ac
after 12 hours yeah yeah
how does the director build strong
relationships with actors
for a first time future director
uh
i mean i would be nervous
um
but the only commodity i had was the
script
and everyone who was
working there
um
liked the script before they liked me so
i
i had nothing um
to do with
do with that personally in terms of like
me
but for me to gain
like the trust of the actors
is
um i think it was a lot of my train like
training and being a portrait
photographer we talked about before is
is
we have to give ourselves
and
and and be vulnerable even to the crew
as well everyone it's not like i'm gonna
walk on the set and say i'm martin
scorsese you know or or whatever it's
like
i'm the least experienced person on set
thank goodness
because you know and just be honest with
that but you know but i know the story i
know it's
inside and out i'm here to make and have
this vision and you i'm here to work
with you guys to create something i
can't even imagine what's that's in my
head so you
you set that out and hopefully um
the team follows and then they build and
you and each day
um you work for their respect you work
um
and show it it doesn't happen the first
day first week it um it happens through
time just like relationships um um and
you know and and i and i'm i'm one to
always maybe i'm gonna be grown up as a
people pleaser so it's harder and like
oh okay do you need this or that or um
so i'm always on edge so um but
but i hope to start like that but
it's a fine line too you want it you you
run you run the ship too you want you
don't want it you want to make sure
things are going accordingly and
and um
and not be a pushover in terms of
of
of your vision you know and you could
take lots of ideas and lots of things
and and you'd be dumb not to
but in the end of the day you have to
take all that information you have to
decide what is best for
for the story and you get to make that
decision and you live and die with it
you know you know so
um as a director you get a lot of credit
but you shouldn't because it takes 140
people 40 people to 100 feet to make it
but if movies is not as successful you
go down with it too but um that's what
you sign up for i guess
did you sell finance all roads to perrla
actually we financed uh
our perler with private equity
on tax
in debt um so a bank
and then uh
that's the three components how we we
got it so we had investors
and then um we we shot in oklahoma that
gave us a um
a
tax incentive to shoot pair
um and then
we made up that tax incentive through
through um
financing through through uh
through a bank loan with that so
that's how we came up with the budget
and we're able to
hit the ground in oklahoma because of
that yeah
so
what happens first the self-financing
you have like your own little chunk and
then you decide what state you want to
go to
and go to their film commission or yeah
so so you could go like atlanta on new
mexico louisiana it's just all depends
and then you you have to
go to the film commission
you you file
um you know an application you gotta you
know if you it meets all the
requirements and even while you're in
production you have to keep really good
books and and records and there's gonna
be a third party audit and all these
different things before so it's pretty
extensive and you want to
have that covered and um
of that but if you were to shoot whether
it's in california vancouver
um
you know for you for for producers out
there
that are trying to raise um a dollar
having a tax incentive you really need
to raise
68 cents to the dollar so that's what
really what that meant because you're
spending
in that state and you're also hiring the
crew
um in that there's supposed to be
a percentage of cast and crew that is
from that that state
um to to uh
you know follow the rules of the
the tax incentives so each each state
will have their own
like new york and new mexico and things
like that
so
it's really um i think right now even in
australia or new zealand because of the
pandemic dimmick i think their
incentives if i read correctly was like
50 or something now so wow they're just
trying to get production going
and then tell me about this loan
oh so um
so
let's
let's say
let's say your budget is 10 million
dollars
and you're shooting in um
oklahoma
and they're going to give you 32
um
so really effectively you only have to
raise 6.8 million
right so
um so but to make the full 10 million
you don't get that money right away
you need to make up that sort of
gap and and things so someone you need
to get a collateral or loan to to make
the
10 million
the 3.2 million
so
that would be a bank or whoever could
give you that you know that's what debt
or maybe there's another um
person that's going to loan you that
money but that's going to be debt so
that's what you know that's what
happened so after you finish shooting
after you do the audit
then
you get the money back from
uh oklahoma after you file everything
then you could pay
back the debt
and that's a gap loan
on that too
that's a little bit that that's a little
bit different oh i see okay okay so it
sounds like you can't get one without
the other so you couldn't just go and
say hey i want to shoot here and i want
incentives but then you don't have your
own quote unquote equity deposit that
you're putting in you've got to have
that first
is that right because you can't go
without any of your own money in or is
that well you can't it
it just depends because if you want the
full budget because that includes
post-production deliverables and things
if you're an independent producer and
you have just enough to to get into
production maybe do another fundraise
or another raise later to finish the
movie called finishing funds just just
in case because
if you just want to get like
in production you could raise the
production
budget
post-production money could be raised
later it just all depends on how you how
you do it
um
for instance it costs to color the film
to make dcps to to um get an editor
things all that that's the all the po
the compo composer sound sound mix but
if you just have enough money to get
into production a lot you know a lot of
it just depends on your you and your
producers and how you feel about that
um you know it's it's tricky
it's definitely uh
you know you wanna you want the full
budget
but if you have enough just to get in
production and then the actors are only
available that time period you never
know if it's gonna go so you're like hey
let's just get let's get just get on the
ground and shoot
so theoretically can you approach a film
commission
for to apply for for
uh incentives before you have any budget
raised
uh they'll they'll ask you if you if you
do they'll that they'll you you you got
to show how much on
uh capital and equity that you've raised
and things uh i didn't fill that out
part out so the other producers did but
i'm not specific on the oklahoma
thing but uh
but we had raised the equity
um
to get yeah to get there and then and
then you have to leave show you know
your bank statements and things like
that so so they know hey you're just
going to say hey i have the budget and
then you get there and you don't and
things like that so yeah they they have
their vetting process as well
and you had originally wanted to shoot
in texas correct that's correct yeah and
and that's because the film's set in
texas i was
i had scouted in fort worth
and um
and things but on
just strictly because of the tax
incentive and we just drove up
three hours on having the same landscape
and
and uh and we were able to you know um
shoot in oklahoma
instead yeah
how did you pitch the company that
helped you finance all roads to polo i
met
red sanders of red entertainment red
productions
through
a
composer our composer named curtis heath
who did a lot of my um
uh short films and they were in for fort
worth and i was scouting in
down there and he was like hey have you
talked to red entertainment i was like
no i haven't and then um
they have offices in santa monica and i
was in la at the time and
sent over an email and said hey we have
a mutual friend curtis
um i've got the script that i'm you know
gonna be doing and um they they read it
loved it we had a meeting and i loved
people from texas and then they were
like
sweethearts and they were just great and
derek and red are just
fantastic folks and then um
i had uh i had my
uh mood reel i had my lookbook i had
pretty much
you know um things this in the things
set up and they they liked it
and then i eventually became with gopot
films and red productions and we we held
sort of certain um
you know uh meetings for investors and
things like that but eventually
we we cobbled up the financing through
separate investors and got that all done
uh
red and derrick were instrumental in
lifting the project even further in
getting the script to lindsey graham who
who worked at
betty may casting and she was just
finished casting like um a star is born
and suicide squad and things like that
and and
and bigger
features but she she like really liked
the script and came on board
and that
through that through that our project um
picked up steam you know and we were
able to that's how we were able to get
um
actors to respond
and things like that and and
and uh
that's how we got lucky in terms of
nailing some of these really you know
like dash and addison and alex um
and the whole crew there um so
through with without that involvement
without red and derrick and you know and
lindsay uh i would have been just
shooting um already perla with my father
in there acting you know so
you know uh uh somehow it just swims up
um and then
mind you we also approached other tons
of other production companies who who we
wanted to partner up with but you know
you get hey we don't get the script uh
this is not for us or we have a similar
project or you know it's lots of things
so that's why i even sit back here
today just thinking it's a miracle that
it
it's even out there for people to see so
um
so it goes back to that question when is
it good or
crap
charles pakowski and i was like man
after just going through this gauntlet
uh i'll re reserve my uh
opinions to myself
do you know why some of the investors
passed did they give you
when when these were people i know you
said that they had said
it might be similar to something i
already have or it's not for them but
when red sent it out to the people in
his network
yeah i again i it has to do with subject
matter it has to do with connection
has to do with um people connecting it
you know like or people wanting to
change the story or people want to do
this or or does it resonate so back to
your question go why do you want to
write this
so you have to find people that kind of
falls in that wheelhouse that believes
the same way
you do
our film is
is about love and pain loss love lust
it's it's it's a dark and gritty film
and it's not
not for everyone it's it's um
to me there's messages of hope but to
others they might see an ugly side of
society that
doesn't hit you know especially
especially so when an investor reads it
are they going to connect connect with
this
you know
so
so you they either do or they don't and
you you go into the next person who who
connects with it and and
and find that um so if you're out there
it's just like first you have to
champion yourself
then find people that would help
champion you
and then
and then keep going i think that's
the steps
when you're dealing with production
companies investors
what do they want to see first a log
line
synopsis of the script
yeah so basically basically on
log line gets everyone if you
make a killer log line i know it's it's
hard one two sentences uh your pitch
deck your lookbook your mood reel
to for them to get
them excited to read the script no one
wants to read anything
so
you know um
that's the problem there's just a lot of
scripts so how do you get
people to read it so you have to entice
them whether it's through that log line
through the look book through the mood
reel through whoever's already attached
or an actor or producer it just has to
and that's what they call it a package i
guess you package things so
it makes them it makes it harder for
them to say no
um
so that's what i would do as much as you
can
so start definitely start with the
lookbook so
least it gives you an idea of of um
what the story is about the mood and
tone
and then you know you don't want to give
a crime thriller to
um
family drama production company
unless they want to branch off and do
something different because they're used
to doing that so just you know maybe
research comparable films and what
production companies that
have produced that in that particular
budget level and then approach them you
know
things like that so um imdb pros will be
your friend and um and just research uh
and then and then just send out and and
i hope someone reads it it took me five
years so
you know
can you describe the all roads to perrla
lookbook how many images are were in it
how many pages all right so basically
it's like a powerpoint
presentation i think mine had like 12
pages
and
you know i'll say the i'll have a
picture
the color palette the tone
pictures from
from
a lot of the pictures because i had
photographed already because of my my
photography so it's already a world that
i've already created um then i would add
you know the log line the tone the theme
and then
and then that's the feel the visuals of
it what this movie
would look like
uh i just and then i had a mood reel
so what that meant was i i clipped
together films
and music
and made like a trailer of how the film
would look like it's interesting because
i just looked at my mood reel that i
created i hadn't looked in ages and you
should see it through the trailer right
now
five years apart to see
the the difference it's pretty
fascinating um
and
our composer and not the sound designer
was like man oh my god just saw that
mood reel
that dance scene looks almost identical
to what we shot i didn't know what was
what you know it's kind of fascinating
so
if you could show what the
what the world you're creating
already without shooting it you don't
you know it's a quicker way than
creating a short film to to to create
that atmosphere at least it will give
you
entice you to read the script that's all
i wanted someone to do but they knew i
knew how to make visuals i knew how to
make sound now you just judge me on my
narrative writing
so
that was my
thought process
and how long is the mood reel
it's like two minutes
you know two minutes or two minutes and
30 seconds something like that
or a previous they call it a previous
two um
[Music]
so i do that now like if they send me
like if um
like a manager just send you scripts to
read and it's something you like and you
want to be up for it to direct
oh yeah that's a great script that's
fantastic i'll quickly throw up a mood
wheel and go this is how i see the film
this is what i'll do
you know
the tone and mood of it
so from understanding correctly it was
about three to four years of this
process of you sending out the lookbook
the mood reel the packaging
for all roads superla
how many people did you actually send it
to
and what was their response time how
many actually read the screenplay
um
i have an excel spreadsheet of everyone
who
i would send it to i don't remember i
don't i i know i kept it because i like
to keep track of it
a lot of people did not read or did not
respond the majority majority of it
i was even
determined to shoot it no matter what it
was of that fateful sort of it only took
one which was
red productions so maybe
out of
50 to 100
red productions
or i'm just i'm just throwing another i
know it was pretty red productions came
on and even after red came on we went to
bigger production companies to kind of
um
get involved and that was
pretty much turned down turned down too
so we just did it on our own so that
process
i couldn't even get my friends to read
it i couldn't get fam like it's that's
when no one likes to read anything you
know even
even
what have you it's it's it's it's that's
why it's a miracle
that derek
was like read it and loved it so it just
took you know it was like oh what is the
story and what's that you know um
so
to
one did
um it took
we i submitted it for quite a few
and it was really just one or two that
responded and then
that was it you know that's all it kind
of took
knowing this knowing that it's very
difficult to get anybody to read a
script is there anything you think you
could do to speed up this process the
next time around uh i think
the next time around um
it's it's
it's getting easier but i think most
people don't make it to the next time
around so the first time around
i don't think there is i think it's just
because we're saturated
and even it's like you just it's like i
always go back to that denzel washington
quote you know you stick around the
barber shop long enough you're going to
get a haircut so no matter it's the
third rejection the 100th or the 400th
you just got to stick it out and then
you're going to get
frustrated you can just get tired and go
i don't need to wait for anyone i don't
need this production company say yes i'm
going to do it and then you set a date
once i set a date
that's when i got
phone calls when i said
november 13th
a specific date i'm shooting no matter
what this train is going then it started
even with actors and even with this
stuff so you have to be very specific
can't go i'm shooting in the fall
i'm shooting november 13th even at 2 p.m
we were rolling first night you know
things like that that helped because
that made it real
you know who it was important to me it
made it real for me so i was like then
whoever i said that to
i'm doing it you know and then so that's
why i was like gosh i'm either
delusional
or
naive or but i think you have to so
that's that's sort of what happened so i
i don't know if i could do anything
different
and the other part that you said most
people don't
they don't get a second
time to do this
i was just looking at the numbers of
something so someone sent the numbers
after your first feature was like you
know
17 percent you know for so
that's not the majority you know
especially when you have investors and
people
so that's my saying as a producer
to have sustainable career is to make
the investors money back it's not about
art you know as a director you might be
able to
but um
that's the fear and you look at the
stats and what's happening
so you have to mitigate that risk
you have to figure out ways to maneuver
that and that's that's the business side
that's that's
not going hey this frame looks awesome
oh that's a great color
color the makeup and this it's
how we can do this again
and how can we deliver it and how can we
shoot it in time and how we get it under
budget
that's just the reality of it and
you know and
that's the brutal part of it
unless you shoot it with your iphone and
you know and and and which is great and
you have crew but
there's only certain amount of favors
you could call you you know
you don't want to not pay people to to
work they're long hard hours and what
they do
they do you know it's there's there's
only so much you know um
i just feel that's just me personally
you don't you know i don't want to be a
production company it doesn't pay people
to not do that you know everyone needs
to be paid so there's it takes a lot of
people to make something and that adds
up to the budget um
so
would you say it's easier for you to get
your emails returned now that you have
an excellent body of work to point to
yeah i think so because you
you have that first first feature um
kind of done so now they can't say oh he
hasn't done a first feature but now they
could say but he hasn't done a thriller
you know there's always something but
the whole name of the game i think
what's important
is
if it gives you confidence it gave me
confidence to keep going so all these
little wins
so if you get any little wind any little
thing keep it because there's just so
many losses so you could get these this
confidence to keep going
now because of our
perlis sleeping plastic on script
i got management opportunity in there
and
there and i had
three other scripts ready to rock and
roll and a tv pilot so i'm waiting on
this i wanted to make sure i'm not
when opportunity to meet
you are you talking to people oh what
are you doing after this i'm not
fumbling and going oh i'm working on
something i was like here
here you go
i've got tons left
and i wanted it to create a situation
where
um it was hard to people harder for
people to say no you know
like i don't want to wait around because
you're waiting around all all these
years so all that anxiety made me write
you know and and do all these kinds of
things so i wanted to make sure i had
things so um so
i was able to um get reps and then they
they now help push prod the projects
um and things and
and um
you know thankful for that in terms of
of of trying to
climb this
hill of who what of creation you know of
of um getting
projects made um
so i'm still learning each day this
whole thing you know so which which um
yeah it's fun
did you approach gravitas or did they
approach you uh we had uh so we have a
um
sales agent uh prince films and who
uh their their duty
is to
get it try to um
get their film sold to different
territories and things and um
i think uh
gravitas uh
uh igor prince reached out to gravitas
and then they they made an offer that
that was uh suitable um for us and then
that was for north america
um so it's uh being distributed you know
um
through offstring platforms cable and
things um
we had a limited uh theatrical release
plan but um in l.a in new york but that
got you know squashed but uh but again
you know we're super thankful for for
just to reach daylight um
you know considering you know
considering uh what so many other
filmmakers are going through and having
their feelings showing up this year and
not even going to the festival festival
route with all the virtual festivals and
things like that we were lucky to
start our festival last year
run and then it ended earlier because of
pandemic so but
but we were able to get north american
distribution
did you have to sell the film in any way
to gravitas or
because you went through this um
uh sales agent
uh it um
yeah so you kind of sort of uh
you have your film
and
you you could either
sell it through different territories or
worldwide and um so igor
he
he does the dealings for that you can go
to gravitas yourself i believe or any
distributor
um
for that matter you know you don't it's
i would equate it to having um
if you built a house
you could sell your house by yourself or
you could get a realtor
they get a commission
things things of that sort so um usually
when you
have sales reps and they have
relationships prior to the you know
because you're bombarded usually by a
lot of films some people answer the
phone more than others and and then igor
took our film through all the different
markets you know toronto
um can
different things so they would have
booths set up and and film buyers
um
would take a look and things like that
so that's the advantage
i would say with having a sales agent
who is there to help push
the sale of your film
but uh we went with gravitas because uh
they had uh you know good favorable
terms they were they were they're um you
know nice folks and
and it was also
you know a situation where
we you know we still have um
international rights as well as well
how has covet impacted your filmmaking
career let's see
i think
just in terms of in in general this
personally and professional you know
it's puts uh
puts everyone at a pause to you know we
talked about earlier like to see what is
important in life what what what do we
want to do
it kind of
makes you think about those kinds of
things um how how it personally has
affected my filmmaking life
is
i think when you go through the process
of owning a business or trying to make a
film
there's always a monkey wrench and if
you could survive the monkey wrench and
it hasn't hurt hasn't um
taken your legs out and and
and you're still standing um you keep
trudging along uh there's
whether
uh you know and i try to have that
state of mind and mentality um okay if i
can't do this then there's something
else i can do while this is happening i
could write i could research i could
um
think of ideas i could uh you know um
chill out you know balance life maybe
spend more time with family more not be
so self-absorbed and go go go so
so those are the things that we all have
to question ourselves every day and then
and then you know i was just talking
with my wife the other day it's like
feels like i've been running for 10
10 10 years running and it just feels
weird to not run
um because
you're just so used to it
then but sometimes you need just to
relax and take it take it off and
recharge
and and think about
you know others beside yourself and your
career and what you want to do and and
you know it's like um
that's that's i hope to try to be better
at in in and and as we all try to
navigate these crazy times and um
so yeah i hope you know we
like i said we still have our pencil and
and notepad and final draft and we could
still keep writing
yeah sorry i have to bring up this it's
cliche but just the scene in forrest
gump where he's running and everyone's
like oh he stopped okay wait hang on
hang on he's gonna speak he's gonna
speak and then all he just says is i'm
tired now i think i'm gonna go home
yeah that's like that's i mean
yeah that movie is excellent in every
single way and it because it's because
those those scenes those moments
relatable it's it's like that's why all
these great the great songwriters are
great screenwriters they they do
something so simple
and it makes you feel like you can do it
and that's the best part
to write a song to make you want to go
and learn how to play a guitar that's
amazing for everyone so
that to
have forrest gump or princess bride or
do these things you're like hey yeah
that's something i want to do you know
whether we ever achieve that
that that's not the case it's just i do
you want to give it a shot and i think
uh you know kovid kind of
for those who even were thinking it's
difficult out there to try to be a
filmmaker just
find your half-price books and buy a
book and read and write and and don't
don't think about what's happening in 10
years think about if it makes you happy
today and if you could write a story you
know i think that's the
important part